Don't talk shit now.
Oh,
perfect.
No,
even bring fucking wine we brought back.
We have two bottles already,
but you'll probably tell me they suck,
which you brought us.
Have a sit down and people can hear you.
Well,
that's devious podcast where Steve,
Steve,
there's no nothing.
You could really shake it in there like it's less strong than sugar.
I think they watered it down or something.
Damn it.
This down.
Lock this bitch Michael Johnson versus [inaudible] data you show.
I think that's a good fight.
Johnson lenses really is a fucking monster.
He is.
He's an end on the ground.
But you know what?
So as Johnson not on the ground,
he's not,
but he good luck getting them there.
Why?
Look at watch son calling the underdog.
[inaudible].
What's his name?
Does he work?
Guinea wrestle over eight years and nobody's really good.
These world class on the ground,
it's pronounced that.
Yes.
Dot.
Who was,
how's he going to get them there?
Michael.
John [inaudible] hard to take down.
Oh,
and his standup spelling and Johnson's wait.
Oh wait,
what are you saying bro?
It happened.
Neil was really good.
But you're underestimating Johnson stand.
So Johnson,
Stan,
I don't think you could say one guy's better than in that situation.
If any way.
I kind of leaned towards Johnson in the stand up a little bit.
Should we do a taste?
Not me,
but didn't,
didn't he get stopped by um,
Dela Rouge?
No.
By Neil Darr.
You wish,
didn't he get stopped by uh,
Ramsey?
Najam?
No,
no,
no.
He knocked him out cold.
He knocked ranzie engine.
Mount Hood.
Ramsey Nugen beat.
That's really good.
Ramsey beat somebody that was really grandpa.
He's off and on.
Great Guy.
Oh,
he's a great guy.
He got her Ramsey got Rah Rah.
Fuck.
Holy Fuck.
I cannot put enough Steve in this goddamn coffee.
I call it Steve Callan.
Hey Bud.
Hey Steve.
What's up brother?
No,
he beat Benito dairy.
It too.
I'm right.
He knocked him out.
Ramsey did.
Yes.
Ramsey Nid gym in a UFC fight night.
No.
Versus Nelson.
It took place in,
uh,
in Abu Dhabi.
That's the one I'll be dominant.
Yeah,
dude,
I'm telling you.
Ramsey,
look Ramsey.
He's had some tough losses,
but he's a bad motherfucker.
He's a tough dude.
Tough dude.
And he works hard.
She'll relax too on that guy was a piece that he was wrestling with.
I mean,
you're saying his last fight
and your Holbrook,
he got robbed.
I got robbed.
It's just bad fucking judging dude.
Really bad judging.
There's so much bad judging.
But you know that Holbrook Kid's tough kid too.
That was a lot of fun.
But Ramsey tagged him.
Ramsey did way more work.
I thought I just,
I just didn't think it was a really big frame for 55 like you look at them up
close,
tall,
long Ramsay.
Yes.
Yeah.
He's a really young guy.
He's just a tough dude and a smart dude.
I just really liked them and I really liked that Holbrook kit to,
no disrespect.
I thought that Holbrook is a bad motherfucker.
Good wrestler.
Real tough kid.
And he took,
he took some good shots to Eddie.
Are we going to bet on any of the fights tonight?
My mom get,
you want to bet the sheriff?
Oh,
I need this tank top.
Let's not talk over people.
I'm sorry.
I got excited.
Shit in the middle of negotiating some Dolla dolla bills here was that they were
negotiating it.
Sorry Buddy.
I'm sorry.
I got excited about in the show who's never heard one of these podcasts before.
You're like,
what the fuck kind of podcast is this?
What's a fight companion?
If you just started downloading podcasts,
what's happening right now is the UFC is on TV,
on Fox sports one we watched the card,
we get fucked up,
we talk over each other.
We talked nonsense.
We make a lot of ludicrous statements that get blown up in the MMA media.
We write three or four articles for them,
three or four articles for these journalists,
and we have a good time.
They're just all in state and I like this and go,
go.
And so we'll let you know if there's,
um,
w when the fight starts,
we'll let you know at the moment it starts because if you're trying to watch it
live,
we're like five or maybe more seconds behind you.
How many seconds,
Jamie?
Like 10 maybe.
We got to watch it when they do this because of the Internet.
There's a really quick call.
Joey's colon.
We're on,
we're on air right now in the flight campaign.
What's up?
Yo,
Joe,
what's up brother?
How you doing?
Hey,
we're doing a podcast.
Let's just do this podcast and Jesus Christ.
Listen to it.
So nothing
red wine.
All right.
Um,
so when the fight starts,
we'll let you guys know at the moment it starts,
we'll say ready now,
and if you can like just pause your DVR and sync it up with that.
There's no,
there's no good way to do this.
The only way to do this really as if like you watch it afterwards and you're
watching it on the Dvr and you've got the laptop there and you sync it up.
Otherwise just be sipping on a 2010 Ganti sound level.
We're not ahead of you,
so we're not going to notice some shit and go,
oh shit.
And then you go,
when's it coming?
When's it coming?
That would suck.
But it's all good.
These,
I discovered these never going eat regular pistachios again.
They're already shelled.
Ooh,
it makes pistachio seemed like nonsense.
That's a brilliant,
it seems to me the fad these days because I found Starbucks the same ways.
Unwrapped starburst on route on rap guys.
Huh?
How do they keep them from Stillman to each other?
Candy boy over there.
What'd you say?
How do we keep them from sticking to each other?
Put Talcum powder on them.
They kind of stick together.
I'm like an idea.
There's a reason those wrappers around that they're not as tasty.
I feel like the rapper kind of seals the for reals.
That's sacred time with this one guys.
Somebody that makes sense.
So what does this wine you?
Um,
you were kind of sewer.
I got ourselves,
I got us a beautiful county at 2010 county.
Um,
and a
casteller.
The Ama Sanlorenzo don't know what that means,
but it's a,
it's an earthy piece of work here.
There you go.
Now,
now the differences,
you're going to get some earth and your wine.
You're going to get some,
some leather and some please don't make me hate you.
I'm sorry.
Don't do
Ray Borg and a boy.
How do you say this gentleman's name?
G.
A.
N.
G.
Change Gene.
Mr. Herrera.
We'll call Mr. Herrera.
Beautiful Body boards.
A bad mother fucker though,
and really good on the ground.
This should be a lot of fun.
That guy's got a great body on him.
Shred it.
You have to be there fighting.
One 55 or 45 six 45 smaller.
I think that's that 40 fiber.
It's a bad son.
Yeah,
that's not good.
That's true.
That's danger.
No one's like,
it's 45 hours out of shape.
It's a job.
Trump triggered the love handles 45 to 55 or so.
It will look a little on the body fat side.
Really thought out the way it's too big for you personally.
I mean my dude,
these guys are one year in my pocket.
You are in my pocket.
What the fuck are you talking to?
Light in the ass.
I'm very happy with Bravo's hair and two man.
Good man.
It's a beautiful,
beautiful man.
He's a beautiful young man.
Thank you.
Rob Was a bit of 45 song.
That's young.
They don't look at Man,
he doesn't look for great beard dot an hour ago.
So yeah,
he doesn't look 45 at all.
Not at all.
Thank you.
Every bit of 28 really 20 2032 33 dude,
they're trying to fuck you
would come up.
We're going to this party.
You should come with us to be just the two of us did think that you can just be
friends with guys.
Have you seen this?
You've seen the moon like 10 and 11 on the beach.
[inaudible] Sushi restaurant at the top of Laci.
Anika Marina.
We'll figure it out,
man.
You're done like one section four 57 on the clock right now.
Yeah.
So uh,
here we go.
First fight of the night,
450450450 right there.
Bam.
So sync that bitch up.
Oh,
I mean,
I'm just going to start on board with a big takedown.
Terrible Wrestling Borg is strong as fuck man.
Every fight.
I know you guys.
You let me know what you think,
but their trunks drive me fucking nuts.
White and black and black and white.
Hey,
how about we switch it up?
Why not red and blue?
The corners red.
It's confusing.
They had a whole warehouse of shit.
Daddy get rid of it.
And that's the first stuff that we're going to,
cause they have to supply them.
How cool is it for the UFC?
Reebok steps in and they give them all this cash and it doesn't cost them
anything.
They're like,
they give,
they give them cash and they get to dress their fighters.
Did you see that?
The Reebok Guy Interview Joe.
He was,
he,
I think he's the president or he has something to do.
He's like the head of some thing with Reebok that deals with the UFC.
He said your ass
is next in line.
It'd be wearing Reebok.
What does that mean?
It means that he basically said they rushed to get things done cause they,
they said,
you know,
how come some fighters names are misspelled?
You know,
there's,
and he goes,
listen,
there's over 500 guys.
What do you expect?
Will for sure spell people's names right and have everyone on there.
That's what I expect.
And then he goes,
you know,
we didn't think far enough ahead.
We just want to get this out so we didn't think about the ring card girls or Joe
Rogan.
That doesn't matter.
I don't have a contract with them.
Well,
you'd be wearing pumps.
My man.
It's just the way it is.
Welcome.
I'm going to wear what I feel like wearing.
We better like pumps.
Then they give you money.
You don't have to do some sort of a deal with Reebok.
I'm not going to wear their stuff for free.
I'm just not.
It just doesn't make any sense to me and I'm not a fighter.
I'm not in the same situation where you get paid for it and I would have to
decide whether or not I would want to do that.
I just,
that's the problematic aspect of this meant there's many,
but that's one of the big ones.
But if they offer you a contract and are like,
hey,
we need you to wear these UFC Reebok pumps for every show.
You know what I like doing?
I like Chuck's me too,
but where am all the time?
Fuck yes.
If con Congress wants to come with some cash comments,
you,
you know why?
Because these are what I like.
I wear these all the time.
It's is all are aware.
There's been amazing Jujitsu going on man.
And we're talking about rema occasionally I'll wear Nike.
Yeah.
And I would wear Reebok it for their cool sneakers.
I don't have like a brand that I love him.
Oh ooh.
Both of these guys are really good on the ground.
Both are really good man.
We're seeing a high level Jujitsu match right here.
Seriously.
These guys are off.
Yeah.
A lot of Jujitsu and thrown in with punches and shit too.
And I don't know any,
I don't know either of these guys Jake shields here at speaking in which,
cause he's going for this Kimora did you see the Jake shields per Horace fun?
How fuck was at is IAA times and stuff like that as Paul Harvey's the most
dangerous guy in the world,
I think.
Sorry,
he's scared he's going to poke in the eye and rip your fucking arm off.
But he's also taken stuff to some crazy different primal level,
you know,
like the eye poking and the then the holding the submission.
Even after all he's been through,
he's been kicked out of the UFC for it and he's still holds submission.
No,
they warned them in the back.
That's why he got banned.
Because in the back they go,
listen,
if you get a submission,
do not hang onto it.
We're not giving you another warning.
This is it.
What's this motherfucker do?
Yeah,
hang onto it.
Jake shells was just owning.
I'm just controlling them on the ground.
And he started poking him in the eye,
you know,
it was just really fun and really messed his eyes out.
And by the way,
his eyes,
his eyes look really bad.
He's just a scary dude,
man.
But he did catch that submission.
He legitimately thought Jay Clean,
legitimately products.
So the end of the fight is not in dispute.
But how did he get,
couldn't see,
couldn't see in round three he could not see.
He was like,
I can't see in the corner.
They asked the Torque,
wanted to call the fight and he goes,
don't call it.
He couldn't see.
He was right there.
They was fighting.
It blurs.
Yep.
Jake shields is one of the best passers and carry it.
He's one of the best pastors in the
whole game,
if not the best,
if not the best.
He's awesome at passing any pass who's a Marpol haulers.
His guard a few times.
And that itself was impressive because Pars is Jujitsu all the way around is top
notch.
She's not just good at leg locks.
He's good.
He's got,
he doesn't have any holes in his head.
He's world class.
He's world class everywhere.
And the one thing that I was really impressed with his,
his,
his side control,
the escapes,
his guard recovery,
if you watched that,
it was beautiful,
the way he dismounted and the way he,
uh,
cause uh,
Jake shields was passing his shit.
It wasn't easy,
but he ruins all that.
He ruins all that being a fucking moron.
This what I'm saying.
Look at this triangle temps.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying is like,
it's very primal.
When he's fighting.
It's like it's animal Shim.
Did shoulder did it get tore off?
Rotate a simple image.
Yeah,
there's damage in his shoulder and his eyes were all jack.
What about mark is guy,
he's just not good.
Oh God.
It just looked in,
has been saying it for years.
So he's the worst referee in the business.
I don't know if he's the worst,
but he's made some fucking chambers.
He made a big air and a Frank Mir,
Brock Lesnar fight this one of the big ones because Brock Lesnar was completely
locked up in a submission and he took too fucking long.
There was tap,
tap,
tap and then he's moving in.
He doesn't train and if he doesn't train,
he's never been tapped.
It doesn't tap especially to a legacy.
No idea man.
He doesn't know how close you are to give your shit to destroy.
That's what big John McCarthy was saying.
He trains every day too and he goes,
I train and keep her the kids.
Yeah,
cause I was trying to keep up so I know what's going on.
A lot of these guys don't train until it got to be in the wrong place too.
You don't tap the guys back.
Hey guys,
get it fully lock Kimora you get in between them.
You let him know without any question.
Don touching his back is not the,
it's not the fight happening on his band.
No.
Paul Horez is a fucking gorilla,
right?
He's,
he's destroying.
He's in the middle of ganking.
He's in the middle of winning and he feels stumping,
touching his back.
He doesn't know what the fuck it is.
Right.
I mean it's almost not his fault.
He knew that Jake shields was tapping for sure,
but Marilla Bustamante who was his coach lost almost lost a Matt Lindland tapped
him and then had a tap and get the,
I shouldn't say almost walk cause he dominated the fight,
but he got fucked because he tapped Matt Lindland caught Linden in an arm bar.
Lindland Seti Tabs,
but then let go and then he caught him in a guillotine and a tall,
you know what?
You can't blame that on Mazda Gotti,
man.
That was who?
Some Marple horses craze.
It's both.
It's a combination of,
it's crazy.
It's both.
I can guarantee you if John McCarthy was referee in that match would have been
different hunting.
He was bold and he got somebody else probably would have taken a point away from
that.
That blade.
Nice century.
As what herb dean.
Yes.
We were shouted her dean,
and he's gouging his eyes and she shields kept going and his eyes were
[inaudible].
He said,
he said,
I'll take care of it.
And Jack said,
no,
you won't.
No,
you,
you're not doing anything.
Do you not say no,
I'll take care of it.
What does that mean?
You're gonna talk to him?
He's going to smile at you and Pokemon the eyes.
That was one thing.
That was one thing for sure.
Maybe Masa Gotti fucked up really bad there,
but if you watched that Kamora that was in transition.
It's so nasty.
So it was a huge transition from the bottom to the top.
And then he switches and uh,
there's just no way he could have got there in time.
I think the pat on the back was like,
this is the quickest I can get here.
Not,
I'm going to bypass trying to stop him and go around and try it.
He was just not in position to get teen rate board.
That's nasty to his,
his legs locked up.
It looks like it's overkill.
It's an amazing the legs you have to do.
All you have to do is get out of that fucking mount,
get those legs separated.
That mounted one too.
When they're doing like a guard from the top when they crossed her legs like
that.
God Damn,
that's Nas Joey Benevidez style,
which was no one Benevidez like right there with a mounted guillotine.
When Benevidez tap Tim,
who was it?
Who the fuck was it?
10 means,
yeah,
no,
no.
Not saying names.
Him to tap with his feet.
His,
both his arms were trapped and getting guillotine bolt.
Design to trap and he's slapping with his feet.
Feet.
Benevidez got a nasty one.
These guys have very good shit.
So let me tell you about being in Brazil,
watching Ronda Rousey walk out into the arena.
We've got 16,000 people.
Originally they were trying to,
like,
there were chanting over her fucking song,
like she's going out there with their song and they're going,
Ooh,
well then you're gonna die.
You're gonna die song that they always saying been there.
Then people are like touching her as she's walking in one slash [inaudible] and
stuff like slapping at their truck.
They have to reach really far,
so they're trying to touch her,
you know that she's not close enough with them to just,
you know,
know exactly how to reach her.
So they're trying to reach like a white guy jumping up,
trying to touch a basketball rim.
Like you can't really do it delicately.
You've got to know passive way to do it.
Best to try to touch it.
But dude,
she walks forward with his fucking stare of death.
Like she didn't give a fuck about anybody else.
All that stuff was just nonsense.
Total tunnel vision and why it was happening.
I was like,
what?
We're seeing some crazy history shit here.
Like there's something about her right now where she's kind of transcended the
sport in some crazy way.
You're emotional,
dude.
I almost cried,
cried,
cried when I was interviewing her because I felt like,
I felt like,
you know,
when you,
I would say that if you could tell your kids,
like I was there when Muhammad Ali beat Sonny Liston.
Did you say though,
I was there when Mike Tyson,
when Mike Tyson beat Trevor Berbick and won the title,
the youngest heavy weight ever.
I was there.
You know,
if you could say that like,
wow,
like don,
my rare always talks about Michael Spinks.
He was there from Mike Tyson,
Michael Spanx.
He goes,
John,
I was in the audience.
I saw him in the eyes.
This is like,
it was a historic event.
You know,
the only differences is when you say those names,
and I'm not hating on Rhonda,
but when you know,
when you say like Evander Holyfield Tyson,
I was there from [inaudible] son.
He listened.
I was there for that.
I was there for Rhonda Verse Pitch Kaleah no Sir.
It was the best chick in Brazil at one 35 they come.
No,
she's not.
Well,
why?
There's PR.
There's Brazilians and rank higher than her.
No,
no,
no.
She's ranked number eight.
No,
but Eddie said the best.
Listen,
listen,
she can't make the weight yet,
but that's a different story.
And she just recently got signed with the UFC.
This is Rhonda is first time in Brazil.
You know it's a first time in Brazil.
It's that when Rhonda came to Brazil,
that's what he's talking about.
And it could have been fucking,
you know what's different?
I think it's different.
Listen,
it doesn't have to be equal.
I'm not saying that.
What I'm saying is it is,
it is without a doubt and historic event.
Fortunately she fights for sure.
5 million Instagram followers in a fucking day.
How many?
1.5 million.
That's this paper view is going to be bigger than UFC one 89 it's gonna be
Connor Mcgregor floods.
She's by far the biggest star.
There's all,
and he's means all over the internet saying don't be a do nothing bitch.
Cause that's what she said.
She said,
I'm not doing nothing.
Bitch sits around waiting for some millionaire to fucker.
And like everybody was like,
Holy Shit.
She's just gang.
She,
she,
she's not,
she's,
she's like a walking example of feminism.
Like meritocracy.
Like she's,
she does it.
She doesn't talk.
He's cheating.
Does judged on a curve now.
She walked out when she knocked her out,
she kaos her and then she goes,
don't cry and then walks away from her.
And social shifts struts around the rest.
She's a different demeanor on a pen.
Dot.
No,
no,
no.
She's strutting around the octagon and the audience has to give it up.
They have to cheer for her district and now,
and now you didn't give us Misha take three.
But in Brazil,
captain negative here in Brazil,
even in Brazil,
they're cheering for her at the wins.
They were booing.
Batchko hey,
in Brazil and the way she is by far the biggest store,
it's not like she's transcended Sally like Conor Mcgregor Flying Irish people
over.
This is actual Brazilians.
This is actual Brazilians booing one of their own country when,
which is unheard of until it,
she's loud and nationalistic country.
I think she's,
she's undeniable and she's,
there's a human example here of triumph over all odds in a way.
Like,
you know,
just to be a woman and in such a short period of time to be the biggest draw
where I was in,
uh,
I was in a with,
how was I?
Um,
I was in,
I was doing stand up in Dallas and I was in this bar.
It was just packed and the minute she walked out and he starts beating,
everybody went crazy.
If you told me that a woman could garner that kind of a attention as a fighter,
I would have been,
I would have told you two years,
three years old.
She's just not like anybody we've ever seen before.
When you say a woman fighter,
you're judging on the women fight or that you've seen the girls that were really
good as like boxers,
like you know,
Christy Martin was kind of fun to watch and Laila Ali was fun to watch to see a
Riker and Gina Carano.
It's fun to watch.
This is another level.
This is some Nice Tyson shit.
She's the female version of Mike Tyson juice.
Pickles are fucking terrifies you to get in there with her.
Did you think?
Did you think that she would dispatch Correia that that easily?
I mean,
I thought she would submit her right before she would rag doll or and maybe beat
are facing with elbows.
That's what I was thinking.
I think if they find a hundred times that fight goes like that 100 times.
It's no competition.
Here's where the fuck she wants to.
That girl.
She does whatever she wants standing.
She does whatever she wants on the ground.
You'll see one,
one lot of honey.
Look at that.
Oh my God.
Look,
a raid board's head is squealing blood.
Look at that.
It's flying out of them.
That is crazy dude.
That is like a broken faucet there.
Stopping it because of the blood gets on his eye.
What is,
yeah,
it's on his cheek,
but he's thinking it's above the eyebrow.
Blood is pumping.
It looks like this is done on his cheek.
It's hard to tell.
Can you tell?
It's like the slitter that I,
Huh?
Yeah.
Oh,
it is on the island.
it looks like more.
Yeah,
it's the eye.
It's like at the slit.
Anyway.
They shouldn't have stopped that.
He's in a really good bullshit,
but they better put them back in that position.
That's where it does.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
That's good.
Think about it.
Think about what you're saying about Rhonda right now and how this is such a
like a historical time and what Callan sand and then even the fact that uh,
uh,
Brendan is like saying like,
well she's not really getting any competition.
Put all that together and then you look at Cyborg,
you know what I mean?
For the level sideboards,
nowhere near Rhonda is level.
Yeah.
It's in the CFL.
Cyborg Cyborg is known as a fighter.
Yes.
Cause if Ron does not face it,
if we're,
if we're going to see if we're going to make fun of Rhonda is competition.
I'm not making fun of for Rhonda Competition.
You are.
Yeah.
And I'm saying Ron's competitions,
nothing.
She's,
that's how much better she is then those girls,
and it's not Ron,
it's faults.
Not the UFC.
His fault.
It's the state of the female fights right now.
It's just,
that's what it is,
is so new and Ron side fucking bad ass.
Did you know what I mean?
Is the best we have ever done?
We won't see another,
but Syep sideboards,
she's just not in the same realm as Rhonda.
Well,
this is because she doesn't get any fights.
I mean,
she's fighting these girls popularity wise,
everything across the board to,
do you know,
if she had a it,
she should have kickboxing bout with this chick Joe.
Her name was Jay Jay.
Oh,
I know how you say it.
Yeah,
she's
the one she lost.
She lost.
She fought like one of the best female kickboxers on the fucking planet.
A chick that can't get a fight.
Nobody wants a fighter in bars is back.
She fought us here.
The distance she went,
she went the distance with her and this was,
which is not our sport because she's an MMA fighter is a big difference.
Especially with the big gloves on the fight.
You know,
it's just not the same.
She can't take people down.
She can't,
you know,
there's a lot of things you can't do,
but that chick,
she,
she got in there with one of the best in the fucking world.
She's trying to fight people,
but there's all the allegations of steroids.
She's failed fast.
Yeah.
If there's no allegation test one test.
Physically.
No,
you're right.
Absolutely.
Look,
I'm not,
I'm a Chris Cyborg Fan.
Let me just say that right now.
As a a fight analyst or a fight fan,
she's fun to watch,
man.
I mean,
I don't know if it's fan.
I mean I,
it's striking and it,
her Jujitsu.
Oh,
she's taught class.
I mean as far as she's a brown belt level on the pill and she's really good.
She's not as good as Rhonda on the ground.
No,
no.
Just close fucking way bigger.
She hits wait,
looks like she hits like a Mack truck.
Any woman like,
and that's unforgiving.
Right.
So if she,
I'll get her to one 35 gallon.
The sear here like that.
Well that's the thing that Robin black had a really good point.
Robin black was one of the best fight analysts out there and good dude.
I had him on the podcast.
Very,
very knowledgeable and a huge fan of the sport.
He's like,
it's bullshit.
All she has to do is eat less and run.
Everybody does it.
You want to lose weight?
You can lose weight.
Fucking 50 cent did it for a movie.
He lost like a hundred pounds.
Look at fucking Matthew mcconaughey.
Exactly.
Matching mechanic.
He could get eight people can do it.
You get it.
You can do it.
People.
What about a homeboy with fucking Batman?
What's his name?
Chris and Christian Bale.
Christian Bale you,
but can you fight it that way anyway to fight even better if you don't ever cut,
wait,
how about that?
How about you let her fight at one 70 that's what she walks around that,
right?
No,
it's bullshit.
There's a reason why you have to cut weight.
You have to cut weight because they're trying to figure out some way we can both
agree on even terms.
I don't think she has any heavier than one 35 pound,
24 or five pounds.
Any athlete.
If,
if,
if Dana called me up right now,
it was like,
hey Brandon,
listen,
we need you to get 20 to five and you can fight the champ at one 85.
I'm going to try my fucking best to make that fight.
I'm sure it's fucking,
I'm like,
no,
no.
We got to do at one 90 note,
whatever they want,
I'm going to do,
especially when I'm Cyborg,
I want to become relevant.
I have to make,
talking about Blues Cyborg,
that's common.
She was walking around.
She goes about one 75 she did.
Well,
here's the thing.
A lot of that is a lot of weight and it's very unusual.
Lot of weight.
But here's,
here's the other thing,
not the norm.
One of the things about,
about steroids,
and this is not saying that she's on it,
I'm not making any allegations,
but one of the things about the people that compete on them is that they find it
very addictive and it's not just a matter of the fact that it allows you to
heal.
It's not just a matter of fact that it gives you,
you know,
this,
uh,
this ability to train harder.
But it also,
there's a confidence thing where you know,
you're on this shit,
you know,
and they all talk about it.
They all talk about it.
Like when I was on it and I was fighting,
I felt invincible,
especially in the female stars from a female's body.
It's going to change some things,
bone structure and attitude.
The way she fights.
She fights like an angry dude.
Yes,
she malls.
So you take that away.
And again,
I'm not saying she's on testosterone,
she's,
she's failed a testosterone test before.
If you look at the two factors,
the fact that she's failed a test before and the way that she looks her flesh,
the way you still look when she was in Strikeforce and she fought Gina.
Okay.
All that nonsense aside.
I think it's worth when we know we know about the sport,
it's worth considering the possible.
I agree.
Right.
That's fair.
As far as you can guess,
that said,
she's just bigger,
she's way bigger.
And this idea that Rhonda has to move up.
Like she actually she doesn't.
Why would Rhonda move up?
Why does she have to do anything?
She's the champ cause to the common folk to the common fan.
Yeah.
No one knows who this is.
A cyborg is,
this is not a matter of her not being able to do it.
It's a matter of her not taking any
of the steps to attempt to do it.
Like if you really want to do it,
what you do is you make that weight.
You hire Mike Dolce,
you make that weight and you put up a fucking video of you making that last
hair.
I'm waiting,
making in one 35 see,
I can do it Rhonda.
Let's do this bitch.
I want my title.
Boom.
Biggest fight ever.
Ever,
ever,
ever.
What do you think would happen?
Shit.
Back at jre one,
whatever.
When Rhonda was on Joe Rogan Show I before the UFC even had chicks.
You know what I thought?
What freaked me out is when Cyborg FOBT,
Gina Carano and strike force.
I worked for the UFC for eight years.
You're used to the crowd and what it sounds like.
I never heard a crowd like that ever in all the hundreds of shows I've been to.
That sounded like a Beatles concert when Gina Carano came out.
It sounded like it was a Britney Spears concert cause she's,
and I thought,
wow,
multiply that times a hundred yes.
Rhonda in Brazil screaming like Justin Bieber was on stage.
It was like Elvis was there.
I think Rhonda Beats Cyborg even at one 45 really?
But I don't think Ron has any reason to why I'm the chase,
I guess fight of all time.
That's the biggest
danger.
Upper Rhonda.
It's a dangerous fight,
but that's what the public doesn't know who Cyborg is,
so they don't give a fuck.
Listen,
if the blood cyborg fought,
if signed right now in the UFC,
how long would it take for them to blow that the fuck up?
And everybody knows who Cyborg is and they'll take a while.
Oh,
it will take fucking one week.
No better.
Let me ask you the line.
Let's look at this rationally.
Let's say would say we know for sure because we don't know anything for sure.
Right.
But let's say we know for sure the Rhonda is not juicing.
She's not doing anything guaranteed.
Okay.
I believe you,
but let's say we know for sure.
Okay.
And let's say we also know for sure that Cyborg might be on something and she
might be on something to make one 45 then are you okay with it?
Are you okay with it?
If they both fight at one 45 and one person is naturally bigger and might be on
something
where they fight one [inaudible] this is my question.
Do you have any,
do you have a different opinion about this with women than you do with men?
Not really.
Here's the thing with Chris Weidman.
Here's a perfect example.
Chris Weidman's dominant champ,
just like Rhonda,
if he was going to fight Vitara and we knew that [inaudible] tour might be on
TRT,
I still wouldn't have a problem with it.
And I don't think why?
Why would we have a problem with it either?
I think Weidman would be like,
I'm going to still three isn't that what,
that's the reason I wouldn't have promise that because someone's already big
trouble.
It's already got a bigger frame and I'll test the point.
It's a different,
it's a different,
it's a completely different,
that's the car.
Just be tourists.
Brisbane's means I end a fucking the next level.
You will never be the same.
Rock Anderson one round.
Tko Dan Henderson.
Look at all these dudes.
He was let seven zero six and we're just Keown dude's take them off
testosterone.
What the fuck was that?
His body doesn't look the same.
He doesn't perform the ceremony clothes.
It's like going from a variety of civic.
So that's the question is like if she's capable of doing something,
she's capable of doing something that's not natural to stay at one 45 or to get
up higher than one 45 and the one seventies then then what?
How do you feel about the fight then?
Cause then because we different fight and then what's the UFC do?
Let's say the ULC let's say they do do that fine and Cyborg knocks rundown.
Yeah.
Knocks her out.
Dead.
Yeah.
And then what?
Then what do we do?
It's a beautiful thing.
It makes everything
better.
No.
Does she lose it?
What if she loses then Cyborg test the sport even more interesting.
No,
it doesn't cause then we don't have our star.
We don't have anyone crossing over into pop culture.
Ronners a plain sentence,
all extra shit.
We
don't need that shit.
You don't mind if someone is on the shit and they knock somebody out like that
and then you find out that the reason why she got knocked out like that is
because the other person was,
I do.
I think it's cheating.
This is the thing.
This is what my,
the sexist in me is sexist in me.
I have more of an issue with it for some reason with women.
Well maybe because
what I'm saying,
I'm not even comfortable with my,
my opinions on it.
Like I'm like,
why do I have a different opinion if it's women and the woman was on something.
I agree.
When me and Rhonda w pardon me,
Rhonda,
we're hanging out.
I would tell her in less cyborg agrees grease to the strict testing.
You are not fighting her.
There's no way.
I haven't talked to him forever,
but um,
you know what I'm saying?
When I was with her and I still care about it.
But the thing is is there's no way you're taking this fighting.
It's fucking the Brazilian Drago with if she's on shit,
unless she's going to come.
Especially she's going to enlist Ivana ten five there's no way at one 45 she's
just a way bigger human.
It's dangerous.
What would you guys said before it just lose the Goddamn motherfucking away.
It's a fucking journeys yet for her to get what the fuck is going on.
Just lose the Goddamn way of all time.
The fuck you doing sideboard in a way of getting down to 35 would cancel out in
some ways.
The Tet,
the idea of testosterone in terms of,
I think it'd be hard to do it.
It'd be hard to do it when you've,
when you've lost literally 45 pounds.
She would also have to guarantee that she actually made the weight cause another
sneaky fucked up thing that people do is they just don't make the weight.
Like Julio Cesar Chavez Jr and his last fight they contracted,
the first five were supposed to have one 68 then they moved to one 70 and he
didn't even make one guy drives me fucking it'd be not one 70.8 came in.
He was out of shape,
didn't fight well fought like through you.
Just a few punches per round but it was way bigger,
way bigger and the guy would land 30 shots and he would lay into and wobbled a
guy and you can do that one the round with just a few body shots.
It was,
it was like literally like a disgusting punches getting close and swing with
club and bill look like you and me in the ring.
Swear to God,
Julio shop a junior is was a big dude and it was tiny guy.
That's like run and Cyborg.
If they didn't agree to one 35 you'd have some shit on your hands.
Man,
that's not going to be good
at one 35 it's going to happen.
And imagine the fucking audience,
every nice grandma and your girlfriends,
everybody's going to watch that shit.
He the whole fucking world in Africa and Latin America.
No,
you don't know the regular person has no fucking idea who cyborg is.
No idea.
But here's a map
move is Misha Tate versus Cyborg is Berlin 40 this is per night fighting
gigantic fight
right now.
I'm going to meet you.
You never had to do that.
I'm not a Tucker is going to be the toughest fight that you should take.
It has ever happened.
And cyborg the toughest fight rather the Cyborg has ever had.
Really Kate would be.
Why is that gangster
gangster.
It's tough.
It's funny.
I'll tell you the only girl that's taken Ronda Rousey into the third round,
but,
and she's destroying your Cyborg hits all due respect to each tape.
I believe Cyborg hits a whole lot harder than they should.
Tape does at 45 I think you're right.
But I tell you right now,
she's got five girls.
I would feel with all due respect,
I would favor me should take over.
Gina Carano Cyborg and Gina Carano was a very competitive fight.
That's the thing that people don't remember about.
That was forever Corrado mounted her.
You're right.
She's better now,
I'm sure.
But Gina Carano MMA,
she was still fucking girls up back.
Fucking still fucking girl.
She was Gina Kolata mounted her.
Shelly scrambled on the ground and it was some controls situation at one 40 I
think Mitch states and give Cyborg some Fritz Shit.
Get lit up.
Nope.
And that,
and then if they do it at one 35 and she fights where the one 35 it doesn't get
past the two minute mark for sure.
I'm going to be able to pick cyborg down a wrestling wrestling's not that good.
It's hard to take down.
Cybex hard to take down and she hits hard.
I think me,
she'll get lit up.
I love me shit.
But cyborg would be too much.
One Misha one the scrambles against Sarah McMahon.
Ceric man's an Olympic medal.
She's about to fight right now,
but she beat Sarah McMahon now.
You know what's fascinating about this whole class for guys are talking about
passionately about women fighters
because with Rhonda,
Rhonda fight up there,
Holly,
Holly Holm,
Holly Holly Hall is not ready yet.
That's the fight that I want to see a fight.
That's the next one I'd want to see.
And you know who's really tough
man,
she just beat,
she was on Invicta.
She's like an old school fight who was really good.
She just beat a new mic.
Irene,
I'll Donna.
Ooh.
She said,
fuck the fuck.
I think if you're Ameesha,
if you're Misha and you came in a different lifetime and there was no Rhonda,
she's,
she's just killing shit.
You know what I'm saying?
She's the best.
She's as good as she is because Rhonda is so God damn good that the aspiration
like the,
the,
the inspiration,
the top of the mountain is so high that everybody else,
their vibration comes up.
She's like the Michael Jordan.
Everyone's trying to pursue that.
She's,
there's something about her man.
She's got this crazy aura championship.
Rhonda Dude,
when I,
I really did almost crying when I was interviewing her.
I just,
it was the,
the moment was so powerful and plus no one,
her story,
no one,
her story with her dad and the whole thing about this girl,
she,
I mean,
whether or not that's actually what she was trying to say,
what she's saying,
she hopes rotted,
doesn't kill herself.
But Ron,
his dad did kill himself.
So that was like,
it's part of her story and she had all this extra motivation seeing her there
and having daughters too.
And just this is all like so much going on and get it
goddamn emotional.
She's so powerful.
I think.
I think what's really important too about the steroid debate and just as we're
talking about whether or not,
you know,
w if whenever we get excited about a fight,
we always assume,
or we'd like to assume that they're in,
in many ways there's an equal playing field.
They're kind of starting,
even though they may be genetically different and stuff,
right.
You want it,
you want to believe that nobody's actually doing underhanded things.
That clearly gives you an advantage before you even get into the ring.
Right?
Yes.
And that's,
that's,
I think that's the heart of,
of real competition.
That's what makes it so much fun.
That's,
that's the sport way too long to think like that.
Brian,
you've been around way too.
My professor,
I'm just saying that's what we,
that's what we,
as I say,
like as a culture,
we want a level playing field and still when we think about Chris Weidman and
Luke Rockhold,
we,
all of us are really excited about that fight cause we don't know if I have or
we don't know what it'll happen and we wouldn't want to think our Luke was doing
a,
you know,
something or that somebody was doing something underhanded to get an advantage
before they even stepped in the ring.
That's all.
I guess.
Meanwhile Ronda Rousey's and some crazy commercial said that's nuts man.
But the thing is this isn't anything manufacturer.
That's what's crazy is this is really her.
She really is that bad ass.
Like her technique is spectacular.
This isn't like look,
with all due respect,
like Paige vanzant is tough as fuck and she's really cute and she has good
scrambles.
But when you see her,
you see a young fighter that is learning how to fight.
It has a long ways to go,
long ways to go.
When you see Rhonda launching bitches through the air,
when she's dropping down on Misha Tate,
after a highlight,
real fucking hip toss,
boons drop drops and some next level tech.
Have you ever taught well as this aura,
this epic person on a podcast?
Have you ever talked about an MMA fighter longer than we've talked about Ron bed
a day?
Well,
because there's so much controversy,
man.
I don't know.
Right with guys,
there's not too much controversy.
Right?
It's pretty cut black and white.
With Ron,
it's not black.
And here's the deal man.
I think the UFC should have more women's weight classes.
I think they should have a one 45 and there's not nothing bro.
I think if they did have a one in fort you built build it and they will come and
build it and they will call it about two 25 he's a heavyweight.
Just don't.
That's true that too,
but I don't think you should have like you don't have to have that many fights.
Like if you have a woman like Cyborg and he,
she's at Invicta and she has these fights in there every now and again.
They're not that often.
And when she's fighting,
she's fighting girls that are way
lower level than her.
Why not have those fights in the UFC?
Why not have everybody aspired?
Cause that's exactly what you had in the strawweight division until you're on
jet check stepped up and became this monster at one 15 just smashing.
Everybody will do it to do do ultimate 45 for females.
I think the answer every female at one 45 fuck exactly it.
That's how been and given us the same old dudes and all that.
Do have one 45 just all house 16 one 45 the answer might be that they're just
too many fighters to begin with.
In UFC,
no,
there's,
there's so many cards they should,
they should find out what Gabby Garcia can cut down to and then focus.
Hold the vision on her and she's done a bed.
She,
she's fucking,
she's so shredded.
Ready?
She's 200 plus pounds.
She over 200 pounds even shut it.
Yup.
She's six years.
She's pretty,
she's six.
She's six foot three bosses.
Four.
I follow her on Instagram.
She could be I think six,
three Spanish.
I was in the elevator with there in China for Abu Dhabi and I looked up my holy
shit.
I thought I was standing next to Brock Lesnar.
I would ask her to carry me in a photo or ask you to carry me like a baby.
Me Too.
She know what she only opponent.
She's gonna find heroin bar like,
cause there's,
you know what?
There she is right there.
That's 200 pounds.
She lost a lot of weight.
She has,
but she's,
she lost
because you know America got millions and millions and millions of fat bitches.
Why don't they just throw a
bunch of fat bitches?
Gabby's just shredded.
Just fuck it up.
She's 105 and Oh,
you don't want to run it.
Drug tests on her and either either,
maybe that surgery that she had made a weakened or chin too,
like she used to have.
Yeah,
she had blood.
She had [inaudible].
It looks like,
at least that's the rumor.
What does it say?
I'm not trying,
I'm not lying,
nor his.
Tito UFC called my manager last time to see if I would fight Rhonda at one 35
December 5th hey Tito.
Hey sideboard.
How about you take a lesson in business one on one and if you'll see if the UFC
ask you that,
you don't fucking blurt it out and tell the world till it's done.
Because now Dana came out and was like,
no,
I never said that.
Did he?
Yes.
Bring it up.
So either way you're not getting,
it's not,
she's not supposed to do.
You're not supposed to do.
That's the number one.
As soon as the ULC says,
hey,
we're thinking about you fighting whoever,
please don't say anything right now.
Let's be honest.
Right now the girl that buff natural,
naturally traumatic,
more been wrestling since she was a kid.
Brian's been doing judo sentence as possible.
When I put my hand on Sarah McMahon.
It's like Gleason t bow.
Wow.
She's just possible.
I don't know.
I'm not an endocrinologist.
They've been doing it with most girls would like to me
that Jesus.
Okay,
let's watch.
This shit is weird that you have women ring girls when women are fighting.
I think shop big brown.
You need to strip down dude.
I'll
do it man.
That I'll fucking do it.
I wear Reebok speedo.
Did you,
are you bullshit me about Reebok saying that I have to wear their shit?
Ah,
no.
In the interview that said,
uh,
we,
we rush this out to get the fighters done and then they said,
you know,
next we didn't even think about Joe Rogan or the ring card girl.
That's another thing.
Just like you were saying about Cyborg,
not talking about that.
They shouldn't talk about that,
you know,
don't like,
they'll see the whole thing super sloppy because people,
they're like,
we know we're taking a lot of criticism on the outfit,
stuff like that,
but they spell people's names wrong.
I know she's stuffing Sara McMann.
She's stuffing her.
Look at her man.
Has his bad ass.
Damn.
She Brazilian?
Yeah.
Wow.
Oh,
she just slept.
She released it wrinkled.
But basically what the Reebok Guy said is,
you know,
we rushed to get this done,
so we've made some mistakes,
but we're learning.
Why are you trying to scare up Joe?
It doesn't matter.
I'm not at all.
You can't really scare Joe.
Listen man,
he's different because the,
you know,
Reebok can say,
hey Joe,
jump and he's not going do that with just not do the wins.
It wouldn't be that hard.
You know?
I would go and watch,
I watched the see a Jo watched the Rhonda a weigh ins from the audience because
they had a Brazilian guy that was injured.
Did you do it?
Not so good.
Oh,
he needs,
he needs work on his enthusiasm.
You know,
Joe Rogan is fine.
I don't know.
I don't understand the language,
you know,
speaking.
Wow.
This extra man,
just trying to get her back,
take it back and lose the position.
Is this,
you know Sarah mcavity?
I'll tell you what's going on the bottom.
What's her name?
Amanda Nunez.
Tough girl.
She stopped,
but we only test them and then you watch Rhonda.
It's like Bro,
Lebron verse,
I'll fucking pickup game in the park.
It's not called Raman versus me.
Lebron was going to play.
He's got,
these girls are strong and fast.
You know Lebron had a big part in that.
Amy Schumer trainwreck can be seen it.
Yeah,
I love it.
The first 45 minutes I was screaming and it was amazing.
Smoothies are great for 45 [inaudible] the best,
but then you know when when you get really Raunchy,
oh she get her in the eye.
She had the,
I'm dude,
she caught it with a bomb.
Damn.
She's a pretty big underdog,
too.
Tough tennis.
They're all tough as this tough dude.
She is.
So Sarah was an underdog.
Sarah's not good on the bottom.
No series was the favorite.
I thought.
Well she probably,
yeah,
because she Olympic medals,
but she's not very good at the bottom and I noticed that in the Meesha fights.
That's a good bag for a long time.
That's a professional.
She's getting fucked up bro.
Name names Bressler who's really good on the bottom.
It's,
that's the problem.
Dominant.
Yeah.
They're so used to being on top.
They spend all their time dominate.
Sarah's moving
taps to it.
She's good.
She's going to tap
into the drafts.
A bad pitch right there.
Amanda.
She makes a shit
to look at that.
She battled her while she
just said she was the girl to be Rhonda.
Wow.
Dan Dear Meryl says,
I got a whole new respect for that.
I can't say she's the girl to be Rhonda because she just got ground out by
Meesha Tate.
Oh,
she's American top team.
Powerful Amanda.
Good flour
groundwork,
right.
The love that she did.
This hopped over the fence.
Fuck it.
Mike Brown.
Good for her.
She's wicked.
She's wicked man.
That's one 35 huh?
Then when she got a new star,
great.
Got a new star right there.
One 35 but she was a wrestler so she was striking.
That bitch fucked up.
[inaudible] McMahon hits hard for longer,
right?
That he should take to fill up.
She's going to beat Ronda.
I'm saying I wouldn't want to watch that shit.
I want to watch.
See are getting fucked us this,
watch this.
Watch this.
Oh Damn.
Look at this.
Damn.
She,
Sarah McMahon broke me.
She's orbital your yeah,
her.
I was fucked up from that.
She hits hard,
man.
First.
Manda battered or dude,
dude,
you know what I don't want to see happen,
Paige vynanse fight.
Uh,
Yolana No.
Yes.
Paige is so damn hot.
So auto is just tall.
I would love to see,
I would love to say,
Hey,
you know what?
[inaudible] is a fucking hustler.
She might be able to pull it off,
but you know what?
I put all my money on Joanna.
I'll never bet against her.
I,
but the bottom line is I would love that fight was coming on right now.
If you just get paid Transat Joanna,
I can't say,
like I said,
you'd freak the fuck out of fights.
It's not competitive.
You wouldn't really care for the fight.
No,
because I don't see his face get destroyed.
Have you ever seen another female fighter?
I've never seen another female destroy a girl's face.
Like you wanted it to Pandiya effort.
That's the beautiful part of the game.
That's why we love the game.
I know when it's a bad ass.
Come on as a funnel,
as a fighter.
Paige vanzant trying to beat up everybody.
Who did you,
she just smashed a,
who did she beat?
She'd be at least Herrick
upper.
Yeah.
She beat the shit out.
Where you sat.
That was different.
It was Derek.
Is that pretty,
is that what you're saying?
No,
I didn't say that.
I think Johan that go on is a monster and she's going to throw elbows at pages
dying piece face.
I agree with Brendan.
100% of that.
All right.
I just think you would shouldn't fight someone if you're now ready.
And I think she's really learning him in May when you want as a six time world
moy.
Moitai cause she's just not,
she's going to have the experience you,
it's going to take down defense is fuck you a page like for fights and then,
and then give her,
give her hers.
I have to be hard.
Donk who is Ben Saunders striking coach now I hung out with them at the Chicago
show and we hung out.
He,
he mentioned that,
um,
Joanna was going and training with the Dutch guys at his gym free gears forever.
They knew that she was going to be a stuff because she's this little girl from
Poland training with all these giant monsters.
He said there was nobody her size.
She was in sparring with big dudes.
I'm like,
she's just,
she's just crazy.
And they knew,
man,
if she keeps it up,
they knew she would be.
She wanted me over in that opinion of fight.
I was like,
holy balls are seen a female lightspeed Har Har Donk say.
That's why I'm saying Pena.
She's the best striker like period period in MMA.
It's arguable.
I said that today and I did some UFC said that town shit today.
I'm like,
she might be the best technical striker and all of them.
The Combo and trying to take down trends.
You take her striking and our comp or take down the fence.
God Damn it.
She's terrible.
She's going to be very hard to beat.
Hey,
she might not know you don't have a good story.
Is Jus Julianna Pena First Ronda Rousey.
Yeah.
That's a good story.
Yes.
Eventually she can get started because she was on the ultimate fighter with her.
You know,
she's Meisha Tate's training partner.
She doesn't like Rhonda and you know what she is mentally as strong as is.
You gotta be to go against someone.
Ronda,
she's very,
she's,
I'm telling you,
I'm very impressed as Amanda Nunez and she's no joke.
No joke.
Are you kidding?
Mcmahon's back to the drawing board and draws.
Good Lord.
Is she ever,
that's,
she has a rough story to every girl is going to be going over each other so much
hair boys.
She has a rough story.
She rough story.
Yeah.
Her,
I think her brother died or something like that and high school.
That's why she started wrestling and some shit sucks.
Nunez crack too,
man.
Everybody want to thank,
I prepare their half.
It's fine.
They're all getting better.
Madigan a bear.
I'm getting better now in the UFC.
Dana White.
Love you.
Well,
how long has women's or my Mary been around Joe in two thousand two thousand
what would you be saying?
Translate.
Thank Eh.
Brian Callin for exact thing.
Here's my big inspiration is my pleasure for me to watch him so much so I wish
he was here and to kiss him just one time.
His Lips.
I know he's married
a nice skinny,
but a beautiful eyes.
What would,
how would Joey translate what she saying?
Listen,
I'm coming for you.
You better
mom.
Put your fucking beans and rice and following a child's at half mass cock
sucker.
That's what he said with Eddie.
Whenever you beat oily Gracie,
he called us up and he goes,
fuck with a child's,
got the flag and a half of mass today.
Flag
things anybody's ever said.
It's got that black hole while I did the podcast the day after,
right?
Wasn't it the next day?
The next day,
which I thought it was so funny.
He's just so brilliant.
He called,
he called us up.
He's just,
he's just like the funniest fucking guy ever.
He was on the podcast when we were talking about suicide.
It was fucked up.
We're talking about knowing people died
and I talked about this girl that I used to,
Dave that died and I said,
Joe,
do you know anybody that ever that ever,
did you ever like date a girl and that she wound up killing himself?
He goes,
no.
They showed up.
You get my fucking,
he goes,
I had chlamydia for seven years.
He's going to fucking infesting digging your mouth.
Funniest thing anyone's ever said in the podcast ever.
I can't breathe.
Tears are rolling down my face.
This is the,
as a pause.
He goes,
no,
they shouldn't
talk about Ronda being some phenomenon.
MMA.
What about Joe?
He fucking Diaz being a phenomenon,
man.
This followers are so,
he's got some followers that would die for him and just super loose.
Periscope.
He periscopes every morning and he smokes a bowl and periscope and he's got like
2000 people watching him smoke weed every morning is the best comedian ever.
Yeah,
I've seen them over ever.
I've seen them all.
I've seen everybody I seen,
I've seen live.
I saw Kennison so I saw Hixon his prime.
I worked with Richard Pryor was out of his prime.
I saw,
I saw bill Cosby.
I saw Rodney Dangerfield in his prime.
I saw these guys in his prime.
I think Joey's better than all of them.
I think he's the funniest guy that's ever lived.
He's the crazy,
I don't want to give up the bit because this new bill Cosby bit,
I wanna know,
aiming and slipping,
sliding here the table and after God damn,
he's funny.
He's the funniest guy ever sell software.
I can get off here.
I'll tell you.
I don't want to give it up,
but he's,
I don't know if he's at the store tonight.
I don't know where he's at tonight,
but God damn,
he's good.
You know Bryan County right after me tonight.
Hold on a second.
I think he's at the store tonight.
I'm bringing him up tonight at 1130 Oh shit.
I'm at the store at 11 it's Dunkin trial.
Bobby Lee Duncan Trussell,
me and Dheas.
She's those power.
Ooh.
Mess.
An hour of power right there.
Yup.
Joey's the best man and he's,
I love him.
He's just a good dude.
I can not love with warm,
so call me,
call you know me.
I mean,
me and Joey are cool.
We're cool,
but who called me like,
how are you doing man?
I love you.
You doing all right?
He said to me,
he goes,
you know Joey Diaz is just a really good guy.
What do you mean?
He was just called me up and said,
asked me how I had done.
I told him I love him.
He wanted to make sure I was all right.
He's beautiful.
He's old school gangster man.
He don't,
he don't want to text.
He just wants to talk to you.
I got to hear your voice.
Yeah,
no.
He goes,
I go,
how come you don't like text messages or voicemails goes,
I'm and secure it with my fingers are too fat.
He goes,
if I fucking talk to,
I know what the,
we cool with everything good.
I love it.
All right,
I love you.
He goes,
well,
losing that shit.
He's right.
He's 100% of the times.
If someone texts you something you're like,
what is that mean is the only guy I talked to on the phone?
Occasionally.
Occasionally,
but generally it's all texting.
You're than effect talk.
I talked to you occasionally.
I talked to Brian on a fairly regular basis and I talked to you fairly regularly
and and that's it.
They can junk and Dunkin and Ari and Ari case talked to Joey every day,
sometimes two or three times a day to Ari.
Ari mumble so bad I can't talk to him on the phone.
I have to buy
those.
Those grounds were fucking New York City,
whatever cause he's still in the yard.
Yeah man.
Dude.
Ari is bawling completely out of control.
His podcast is killing it.
It's always like top 15 top 20 on iTunes in the comedy section,
selling out everywhere.
It goes on tour internationally for like a month.
He's doing a month,
like in Australia doing a month in Scotland.
Putrid his does whatever he wants.
Has has an apartment in New York City that he's got somebody else at least is
it.
While he's not there,
he has like a laptop.
He has my old couch.
Oh,
he sold it.
He's not materialistic at all.
Like he's the most unmet materialistic guy,
but he's got money for years now.
He's just the saving it world away all his money because he doesn't spend that.
He's so frugal because I was trying to get her to buy a nice car.
I was like,
dude,
treat yourself to like a nice BMW three series here who come and try my car.
I'll let you borrow my car for a few days of fruit will over here.
Just give me the best.
He's always giving best.
She more like,
Joe's always been that way.
I think it works.
I don't like that.
You know what,
I,
I have the exact same way.
Me and Joe are a lot.
We,
we have cars that have trash everywhere.
Our office is a fucking disaster and I don't like to think about money.
I go like the day I went to cheesecake factory,
me and my wife and my son,
$40 check.
I tipped him $15
$10 sorry.
Yeah.
I'd leave a stone cold 50th I was going to say it on the spot 40 we were in
Seattle and Joe,
check this out.
We're at the airport and see,
I don't want me and Joe and we get coffee.
I just get a coffee and Joe goes,
he put a put,
it gives the guy money and then I see him put something in a jar and he just get
out of here and I really don't.
I look and it's a hundred dollar bill on the tip jar,
and I go,
the fuck.
He goes,
yeah,
I call that a love bomb.
Then I get the fuck out of there.
He was so aggressive.
I put $100 until I get the fuck out of there before they even know what the fuck
happened.
Like aggressive.
I was like,
take it easy,
man.
[inaudible]
guy who you don't want credit for it.
You don't want to see like,
Hey,
Matt was office.
Give me 100 bucks.
You don't even want to get doing.
Get out of it.
Yeah.
Get out of there and know that when you're over by gate 22 this guy's going to
have a good feeling.
It was too.
I love you for that.
You don't feel it,
but they feel it.
If you can make someone feel happy like that,
but it doesn't bother you at all.
Whether or not you have an extra 20 or an extra 50 or a hundred I don't know.
I don't,
it doesn't mean cal or talking about that real killer Tom about this the other
day,
like if,
if someone needs money,
I just give it to them.
I don't give a fuck me.
I stopped loaning people money a long time ago,
but I've given it give it to you.
I don't expect anything back.
But because if I expect to get it back,
then we're going to have prompts and then there becomes this weird kind of
dynamic between us.
So if I just give it to
people and then whatever,
man.
Yeah,
I've had a few friends see what happens to red wine.
You just keep drinking it.
I mean,
I'm doing good.
I'm not Joe Rogan,
scrooge McDuck rich,
but I knew,
all right,
you guys are on your way.
That podcasts is goddamn gigantic.
I see those shirts all the time.
I see the sex,
drugs and podcasting shirt the most.
For some reason I see that bitch everywhere.
Look that sexy motherfucker.
A lot of this is a good God damn fight.
Great fight.
Who else is that?
Is that our Arlovski and Frank Mir on this one too?
Dotson and mighty mouse.
Yes.
A Lawsky and Frank Mir on that car because it sucks cause these are two of the
most talented guys in the UFC.
Mighty mouse might be the most talented in the world by far in the UFC,
but it's not.
These two can't carry a pen,
a paper view.
They just can't.
You know what it is,
man.
I really think that it's going to take some time,
but I think that mighty mouse,
he's such a good guy.
He's so well spoken and Dotson is the same thing.
Dodson is just spectacularly fucking talented.
He's just gonna take a while before people realize it.
But I talk about it as enthusiastically as I physically can.
I know I'm very,
I'm very high on this fight.
I can't wait for this fight like some Russian destroyer to come in and make it
happen.
[inaudible] the fuck he got popped for ped.
She tested hot EPO.
He was on EPO and mighty mouse still ran a train on it for five rounds.
Chinese guy comes in with like some serious [inaudible] you need a ride.
You know what I'm saying?
Julie outfit brothers going at it at the flyweight.
We need it.
It's tough,
man.
It's a tough sell Brazilian of we see a Brazilian.
That would be interesting.
More Small Brazilians killing the game.
A little tiny Brazilian who's killing everybody was like,
that'd be dope.
Yeah.
You said something very controversial recently that the MNA media picked up on
surprise.
You said that the Brazilians are,
they have a four p four part diet.
You're like Jujitsu's wrestling steroids and the other one God,
you guys saying you got heat for that guy to get death threats.
There's one guy,
he's like,
fuck you mother fucker.
You fucking fuck mother.
Fuck.
He was buck 50 times.
I was like,
I get death threats now.
I got a legit point,
man.
What you got to look?
You know,
I've heard Matt accusations behind the scenes.
It's like mad accusations and I can't talk about it cause it's not responsible,
but it's that old thing from the fucking CNC music factory song.
Things that make you go,
yes.
No,
I just don't throw these bombs out without having information behind it.
But again,
there's certain stuff I can't talk to about.
So I throw out these bombs and I get the people just talking shit to me.
Like,
Nigga,
I didn't just make this shit up.
That's idiots.
There's stuff I can't talk about it.
You're coming from a place of knowledge.
Some due to works in a tire shop was talking shit.
Yes.
There's never strapped on a cup.
Yeah.
If anybody's allowed to talk about it,
you know,
this is a big fight for me,
man.
I really am into this fight,
this,
this last fucking Goddamn fast.
He's ridiculous.
And not only that,
John got to Knox,
mother fucker's dead.
We got him,
he knocked out Tj Dillashaw.
Look at this.
Look at that.
Come on son.
Who the fuck naps guys out?
I agree.
Why wait that he's so powerful.
Ma,
me and him is my second fight.
Ever.
Look at him.
Listen to this.
My second fight ever in Washington and I have my headphones on and John Dodson.
I in the same locker room because Greg Jackson was corners.
It was by far my biggest fight at the time.
Only second fight ever and I was fighting this Olympic wrestler.
Johnny Curtis and I have my headphones in and I'm so nervous.
I'm like,
fuck man,
this wrestler man,
he's got to dry hump the fuck out of me and I'm getting ready to walk out and
I'm listening to Rihanna in my headphones.
I forget which one was like more of an uptempo.
Cheers.
Tim Johnson's mustache.
Before we go any
closer,
Kudos to you.
Pseudo continued continued,
so I'm walking up for this big fight in John Dodson goes,
hey,
we don't know each other very well at all.
He goes,
hey,
listen to Rihanna men.
I went,
yeah.
He goes,
fuck,
that's lame.
I went,
oh,
I don't know.
Oh,
thanks man.
And they just kept walking.
I'll never forget that and then fucked as lazy.
I was like,
fuck,
that's lame.
That's fun.
Literally as I'm walking,
well,
he's been beyond the guns,
so he's a silly yes dude.
He's silly.
He's working at buffalo wild wings at the time.
Wow.
Both their mustache off this guy.
Usually it's a pedophile thing.
He's an ass it off and we'll show handsome.
You're Charlotte's a bad motherfucker too.
He's a team.
Take down big boys with Hendrix.
One Hendrix,
Tyron Woodley fight.
Ooh,
that's interesting.
That's a great fat.
It is.
Look at that.
Goddamn Tim Johnson Mustache.
You know what?
Real soon that that's going to be popular amongst high high school kids.
I agree.
100% mustaches.
Oh,
I'll be the first one here with that bullshit mustache.
Just fucking,
this doesn't look good on you sir.
Well,
you don't know.
Slowly.
So once it goes down,
it goes down.
I've seen it go on,
like saying that it's going to come back.
It doesn't come in.
That place does.
He could.
You could work on that.
I figured out a way to,
it comes in,
it comes into my contest.
I know what's going to happen is it's going to come and it's going to be
popular.
Everyone's going to have one does Tom Selleck mustaches.
Then it's going to get played out too and it's going to be gross and then the
new young kids are going to look at you when you're older.
What that mustache and right back when he looks at how an overgrowing musketeer
everything when it comes to style and fashion.
Cause at one point the Burt Reynolds a child molester mustache.
What you fucking know?
They kind of came in.
They came back for a little while and then they fade it back out.
Look at beards are so in.
Who would ever know they're coming back?
We had the numbers would look cool.
Beards are going away now though because beards are like a fucking tramp stamp
like everyone.
So everyone has one.
Beards are pretty strong.
I'm telling you they're not man.
It's on its way.
Yeah.
The Way Joe is,
where his is what's in right now.
I'm a trend setter.
Bitch.
I've been doing this.
It's called being read Gq every week,
five o'clock so yeah.
Oh my God.
I'm going to rule that shit.
Yeah.
What about me?
What she was doing five o'clock before.
It was cool because I was lazy.
I'm not going style.
That's what I just said,
which is just said that that's called being lazy.
Oh really?
You didn't even listen.
Oh my God.
I'm ripping off your subconsciously repeated punchlines.
It's seconds later.
It's an echo.
The beard and skinny jeans is like a tribal fricking band.
Tattoo.
Cardigans went away.
They were in for a while.
Guys.
We're trying to look lame on purpose rolled up.
Pants seem to be in.
A lot of guys are rolling up the bottom.
Oh,
she's not mad at that.
I got to turn you on.
Turn you on to these fucking jeans.
They're called barbell jeans.
I just started wearing shit was tight to wait.
What are they mother fuckers,
dude,
these are out there made out of like the stretchy.
Oh,
and then they bounce back.
I sweat pants.
No restriction.
Stretchy Jean.
Totally.
100% has been wearing them for a while now,
but do the loose a good stretchy jeans street.
Good for turning side six guys for guys.
What?
You get jumped by Ninjas?
Don't worry about it man.
Like for real,
for the most comfortable jeans I've ever worn by.
When did
tramp stamps get uh,
like a gross on a dude.
What year on
your memory is?
No,
no.
I wish it could be your lower back arch your back like your lips and let me see
what's going on.
Nothing.
I'm just checking that he had a back cause you defended the shit on his cock.
Sick from doing the guard.
No.
One point it wasn't not cool.
It was probably was never.
But at one point nobody had never cool bro.
No.
For males,
it's always been
telling me the first dude that got a tramp stamp,
people thought he was gang.
He came to his daddy's buddies.
My cat.
That's a bad idea,
bro.
If you're a Tommy right away,
right away,
right away was never cool.
Now if a girl has it,
I I see a girl with that.
I'm like,
Yo,
do you have good pants now?
My Dad sucks.
Cool,
let's talk.
I do those kinds of guys,
but for a girl even,
it's kind of not cool right now.
Well now it's a little slutty.
Girls.
Girls still get no Sam.
No,
I don't even get them.
Listen,
if they hit the risk at an all time low ribs,
right?
I think if we saw a graph of the tramp stamp,
you see 1993 the fucking pink and then Bam,
that's run by 2015 that's it's fucking screwed.
Where do you get them?
It's true.
There's not as many,
but if a girl has something artistic back,
they're like really good work.
It's like to,
the tribal stuff's Kinda like,
um,
why are you doing that back there?
But every now and then you'll see something that looks really good.
He's like a Yakuza Tattoo.
That is so rare.
I don't give a shit if a girl has a tramp stamp.
If she's who gives a fuck if she should started a website,
still good tramp stamps.com I'm sure it's out cook is though.
It is.
Now.
Let's see if really good Trump's,
I don't care if you imagine a guy,
a hot chick,
she's cool.
She's making you laugh and then you turn around,
you know she has,
and then you're like,
oh no,
I'm fucking,
I'm out of this bitch.
Oh No,
no.
It's what guys,
really good.
Tramp stamp.com does not exist.
Anyone listening get booked it.
Hey,
hey,
this heavyweight fights that probably not going to lie because they're both
wrestlers knocked out.
Let's see what this fire,
you have a trip that she's pretty much,
no.
Did you see the new Brazilian ring card girl?
Which one?
New One.
Tim Johnson and Jared Rochelle.
Yeah.
Well there was a bunch of really pretty ones,
man,
for this new one I just saw the other day,
I almost fell on my seat.
Tim Johnson.
Jared Rochelle,
Tim Johnson's one.
It looks like Bronson from that Australian movie.
English movie.
Was it English?
English,
yeah.
Big Fat Guy.
Tom Hardy was the actor,
right?
Correct.
English.
It was like a couple of big white guys.
Big,
big was big.
Fucking giant white.
Lot of flesh flying around.
Right now.
Lot of stakes,
like this is a different stakes when you're fucking dealing with a 230 pound man
punched near Right Brennan.
Yeah.
Jab will rock your world.
You were talking about that about the two 25 divisions.
You've got a good point man.
I think that's,
that's exactly the right weight to I think 25 minutes because he's talking
about,
you know,
if,
if I weigh in at,
you know,
I've waited and as light as to two 31 to 32 and then I finally guys to 65
basically 35 pounds,
30 pounds heavier.
That's insane.
And you would get a lot of those guys cut and wait.
Then you would get a lot of guys,
I mean we have guys that have cut to get to two 65 right?
Oh well Tim Silvia [inaudible] so Paul Laley,
he just lost,
right?
He had to cut the two to 65 I was there when Tom,
Derek Palae when Tim Silvia was,
I was most muscular best when it was like when he beat Rico and like those those
days.
Tim Silvia was giant and he was look at that guy.
He used to cut way to get to two 65 a lot of people sleep on Tim.
Sylvia,
I'll tell you what the t the Tim Silvia that beat beaker Rodriguez,
he was a monster.
One of the best heavyweights,
especially at a time would be one of the hardest heavyweight subbies show
eight something crazy like that.
Crazy.
Take down a fence.
Great.
Stand up.
That motherfucker was bad that Kim Sylvia and Sylvia and get enough credit hamus
fuck super game breaks his arm.
He's trying to punch them in the other name and no.
Do you remember the Nigga verified?
Yes.
I don't know Carolyn guilty.
How cause he reversed it.
He bade them into it and reverse guillotine and pay it.
Hell called backpack.
Backtrack.
How was it when the went up from half guard and he let him get up and then got
on him.
How did he get to half guard?
I Fall Garden.
Did he pull half guard?
Pulled Garden?
He got hit.
He got tagged to get hurt.
He pulled guard?
No,
he just,
when fresh shitty single and then he panko sweats.
She got on top right top half and then Guillotine de [inaudible] the kitchen
couldn't take him down.
Didn't anybody
didn't tell you was fucking them up standing so,
and he couldn't take him down and he was like,
I'm losing this motherfucker.
I can't take them down.
So what did he do?
What he needed?
He said I got to pull fucked to his back.
He wasn't guard by going with a fake takedown,
like a shitty single and then came and then he just swept him.
He outsmarted them and then baited him into sit up,
grab the neck and choked him out too.
There's just like went right through.
He had to pull guard to get that fucking doubt.
God Damn tough is no guarantee.
You see the fight with Stephan struve.
I wanted to jump out of my TV and be like,
can someone please stop this man tough.
He's too tough for his own good.
He was getting way too tough.
Destroyed his body was getting just smashed.
My face felt that made.
That made me feel sick.
Speaking of great heavyweights,
fade or talk with the UFC,
why they just stop this,
why they separated them.
The shows happened.
What do you think you just give them for doing right away and say,
fuck the world.
Fuck the world.
We're going to do it.
Fuck you guys.
Shut the fuck up.
Let's do it.
Have to be so aggressive.
Yeah.
It wasn't easy breath.
There's going to be the solid brother should have to earn his word at the top.
It's fade or no,
no one's really gonna say that.
I had a guy call people complaining.
Oh,
no matter what you guys signed,
I lost a big foot row.
Rochelle.
Just trying to get the full amount Armour shirt.
Let go of these heavily out man.
He said full mount.
Oh yeah,
he is know for sure.
Like dumb.
He doesn't know what he's doing.
He has no,
he didn't go von flue choke.
Yup.
Jump over to the other side with both feet right here.
He's going fun for him.
He's got an arm triangle has been flu or Kamora go to the other side.
This side's von flue let go,
let go,
but he still saw,
I had a Fox reporter call me.
He's like,
Yo,
I want you to get your thoughts to fight and fade or like there's,
you got no interview man.
There's,
there's no thoughts.
I don't even deserve to fight that guy.
You just know you're a loose cannon and he'll say,
don't want to say some.
They know his drop some bombs,
not when it comes to fade or though I was just like,
I got nothing for him,
man.
I went disrespect that guy like that.
He's a fight for the title.
I think he goes right to them.
If they wanted you to find them.
If they said,
hey,
we need,
let's get fade or in here,
we'll introduce them up and yeah,
we'll get him Brendan shop.
You wouldn't do it.
I probably would for Fader,
but then not going to do that.
They're going to get that he needs to go right to fade or
you never know.
You never know.
Shot with some good sides.
It doesn't make sense,
man.
I personally,
I'll give them right to her doom.
Alaska's.
Yeah.
Let's not give him any,
let's just go right to what he wants to rematch.
The story is the rematch.
That's the story.
Let me ask you this about these shorts.
Are you allowed to wear regular shorts or a tight shorts?
You Pick Reebok makes bowl.
Don't you think they should just go with only tight?
So the,
the grabbing them is no longer an issue.
No,
because some guys are self conscious about and they don't want,
they don't feel comfortable in tights.
So you're gonna force me.
We were fucking tight around or were
grabbing shorts.
It's not a promise,
not a game changer.
Problem.
Oh it does come up occasionally.
Yeah.
But it's not like
holy shit.
These guys could grab him.
Show up.
Right?
Yeah.
I feel like it's like 75 it's 1% or one 10th of 1% of clinch situations.
You can avoid that.
True.
I'm not trying to see fucking not a problem.
This dude with the mustache and some tights though it's bad for marketing
umbrella is Rochelle.
He's just so goddamn big.
They look like tights.
I like that American flag.
Just chest pull a chair.
It's an interesting,
he's American.
Underneath his skin.
I got hard of American called America,
not like this fucking guy from Australia that used to be in prison was that to
fight down that guy,
it looks like a moon looking Australian.
Prisoner body.
Oh Man.
As he could in his body is
it's got to relax.
Relax.
Not just a big guy fucking you,
but feeling his gut,
his gut wrap around the sides of your ass.
Fuck Chris,
touch your shirt.
And that went through my mind thought,
if I lose this guy,
he's the worst body I've ever seen.
How dare you?
How dare you just gotta be a God that God is.
All they have to do is just not eat the same foods.
You know what I mean?
That's the thing.
Oh,
we've kind of rocked him.
the standard American diet.
I mean these guys are big giant dudes.
But listen,
it's real simple.
Calories in,
calories out,
100% of your body's got.
If you're carrying around that much body fat,
you're taking in too many calories and the wrong kind of calendar,
which is still to 25 but is there a benefit?
Is there a benefit to carrying a little body fat like these guys are,
if you don't have a weight limit and maybe you're not as big as say a big foot
silhouette,
a little black boy,
Tony's just,
he said,
fuck it.
Fuck it.
A Tam for what Talary stitching looks but forget about looks.
Is there any benefit to having this extra weight?
Like especially if you're on top,
they'll know.
What about that much of a gifts rather unsightly,
unsightly difference.
I think it's rather than I ever had a backpack,
you ever take your backpack off and he's just your laptop in it and some other
bullshit get off and you're like,
Ooh,
that's like,
that's like 10 pounds fighting me.
These guys might have like two or three fucking backpacks on all the time.
They just,
you're used to it.
And if they got rid of that shit,
they would move a lot better.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's not a cool,
that's a good analogy.
I never looked at it.
That's a great analogy.
Fucking good.
When you take a letter back back up and be like,
holy fuck t shirt off and feel way better.
Yeah,
Dude,
look,
I've worn backpacks,
but when Rinella and I were hunting Brian and we were backpacks and carried
rifles for miles and miles,
it's annoying when you could take that stupid,
I don't know how much is a rifle way.
If you're like a feather,
25 30 pounds.
I don't know.
Yeah,
it was my rifles.
Pretty heavy to heavy rainfall.
When you,
when you take that rifle off and you set it down,
you know you're,
you feel lighter.
Yeah,
but I think it weighs about 15 pounds,
right?
A rifle.
Well,
it's probably at least
15 let's say 15 minutes of really heavy.
Right?
You're,
you're ready for that.
I bet your rifles 20 it easily 20 pounds,
but either way,
the bottom line is,
is awkward and you're carrying all that weight around.
You've got fat around your legs,
that that impedes your legs from moving as quick as they should for sure.
Especially like kicks and stuff.
Could you imagine if you had to throw kicks and you had like five pairs of pants
on how good they mentoring that would be the,
well,
first of all,
and this is the way that Johnson dude,
that Belize not helping me,
the way that Johnson Dude looks training for eight weeks now.
Think about when he says fucking retired.
So
I know this guy's in good shape,
shape.
He's in the middle of the second round still kickin once he retires,
it's the off to the races or didn't Bahar say that about Jake shields at Jake
shields was greased and he says about everyone and we thought that about Nate
Marquardt but in a cool story,
they weren't Marquardt put rubber pants on.
He got a real good sweat before he went out the exact reason it was going to
come out.
They're sweaty.
Yup,
Yup.
With shave your legs and all that shit.
Not what happens in the forest now where we were suspended and they took away
his title.
They stripped him of his tied well deserved.
Well,
I think they're going to bring them.
I mean,
if they get rid of them.
Ooh,
Rah shot looking for that.
I had norm.
I think if they get rid of him,
he goes to Beltour.
I think Bella toward being crazy.
I agree.
For sure.
Crazy to not take him.
He's got so much controversy behind him.
The bad.
Everybody's afraid of them.
Let me just get them some IOWASCA therapy.
Take them out to the fucking jungle.
Give him a straw dog.
Give him a fucking coconut with a straw in it and it
goes,
hey,
I need,
he goes,
I need you to do me a favor.
You need a what?
Paul Harry's ass.
I ain't whooping his ass.
No,
I'm scared of that.
My phone touches everyone else.
I'll give you steal.
I'll give you,
I'll give you ankle,
steel,
ankle girdles and goggles.
Will it make your organization look bad if you signed him?
Well,
the public turn against that organization when they start petitioning.
Don't give a fuck.
That can share mucking Kimbo slice of Americano,
looking at 10 different looking at Texas Shit.
Lefthand stop defending.
It's thinking it's happened.
He look at that hand has thinking,
yeah,
but this is okay up here.
Up here is okay.
It's really when you get it down into your body that it's just,
you have no free.
That is he not know.
Oh there you go.
Sometimes guys just don't know about just sucking it up next to the guy's room
or he's exhausted.
That's possible.
But they're focused on the arm that's being attacked and said again using the
other one to escape.
That's the way out.
Well the guy on the bottom.
Yeah,
but the guy in the Bob,
the guy that's up,
once you have that double wrist lock,
you gotta concentrate everything on getting the fucking elbow to his side.
That's everything.
Getting the elbows to the side changes.
Yeah,
we'll bring it down.
I think he was going for the Americana.
Right,
so he's good.
If he brings it down towards the rib cage,
the amount of movement that you could tolerate,
so small range up here,
you could use so much range up there.
A guy can do right.
If a guy has really strong
like some allosaur ovary,
motherfucker can get you up here and it'll hurt.
You'll just tap just cause you know it's going to get ripped apart anyway.
But anybody can get you down here like once that thing gets down to your ribs.
Boy though the tolerance of the shoulder joint movement,
the powerful Rhonda in another commercial.
Jesus.
That's her.
That's her fourth one.
I think.
What's,
what's overrated?
Well,
what the fuck's up with over and over him.
Junior dos Santos.
I just call it today.
I did a countdown thing for today.
What?
That's official.
I don't know,
but I just leaked it.
Sorry,
going down.
Oops.
When's that going down?
Sometimes I do things that don't ever take place.
Those were with a bunch of fights that I have John countdown shows for that have
never taken place.
I did two theoretical fights today.
I did two theoretical fights.
It may or may not happen,
but they haven't been signed.
That might've been one of them,
I forget.
And the other one was Cyborg.
No,
I didn't do that,
but I've done some before with the fights never took place or you know,
along the way it falls out.
Something falls out.
People get injured.
I think they've been fighting,
they've been trying for this fight for a long time.
But what's going on right now is that junior is coming back from surgery and
there had been the same at those cane fights.
Man,
I'm a big junior fan,
but he's never been the same.
That steep a fight that he barely won.
Yeah,
he's just,
no,
you can't go that many rounds.
You don't have so many rounds of career,
man.
It sucks.
It's 100% true.
There's no way anybody can avoid it.
It's just the way of the game.
And we've seen it too many times.
There's no one who gets out of it without,
I mean even Mark Hunt,
when Steve Bay beat the shit out of Mark Hunt,
that was like,
you could see,
you could see that this is a different mark on this is this is a Mark Hunt
that's like at the end of the line.
Well,
I was talking to toffees.
He is,
I was talking to my buddy,
Cody is tough.
My Buddy Cody goes to Vegas to have his brain research by some cleaning.
They're,
and they're,
they're using fighters and they're doing a lifetime test where you go every year
and they do five years,
10 years.
And Cody went back to her is five years until he did it five years ago.
And they said,
when you get knocked out,
it affects,
it depends on your,
on you,
on your brain.
It can affect certain parts.
For some people it's the way they act,
the way they think.
For a lot of people it's their motor motor skills.
It just depends from a lot of people if their speech.
So he was saying it's just a pans on the basis of the way your brain's design.
And he was telling,
uh,
Cody that there are certain fights and he was,
he's having Cody go through all this fight history and he goes,
there's certain fights where for whatever reason you took one punch and you will
never be the same at the hand.
Doesn't matter what you do,
but you will never be the same kinds of facts and certain parts of the brain
that will never ever be the same again.
Yeah.
We,
I had a bummer cure from mixed martial arts.com on the podcast and he was
talking to me about this guy that we knew that they told him he could never get
hit in the head again.
They're like,
don't ever get hit in the head again because,
because um,
of what she's been interest just crack too many times or one time too many or
you know,
you can get head kicked,
especially if you get head.
Yeah,
me hit,
it's so hard and
nasty,
mean code time timeout with our original team.
You know,
I'm not gonna mention names,
but we're going through it.
I'm like,
Bro,
who's doing well now?
Who's the same mentally that we can talk to?
There's not many men,
there's just not many guys are this.
And we had a ridiculous team.
If you're watching a guy like sailor Anthony,
Pettis,
Anthony Patterson,
and knocked out,
show on with that nasty head or knocked out Serone with that body kick.
How many times can you let Anthony Pettis kick you before you never the same
again.
There's a certain amount of numbers you can get hit with.
That guy hits you so fucking fast and hard.
And when he hits guys,
they,
they slump,
they blam and then they slump.
Like Lozano.
Lozano is tough as fuck.
He watched that head kick and you go,
Geez,
the I quantified.
Yeah,
Joe.
It's like,
you know,
it's tough man.
But the thing that people forget,
you're only going to get those crazy hits.
The body doesn't know whether you're doing an training or you're doing it for
money.
He does not know if it counts for the EOC or in training.
What did you see the glory of Joseph Valtellina relinquish his title for?
Because of course can post concussion syndrome.
I didn't see that.
[inaudible] is the,
was the glove champ bad?
Not Super Bad.
Right up there with Nikki Holt's can.
They had a great fight and it's,
Nikki stopped him in the last round.
Nikki was winning the fight,
but it was a good fight and mark the ball and he's another guy that he fought.
He had kicked a bond,
knocked him down.
I mean,
he's fucking very,
very high level and he goes,
you know what,
I gotta stop.
I gotta stop and take some time off.
So he did commentary in this last card.
This is just a,
it's a reality that everybody wants to avoid.
It's a part of this because it's,
it's everything you do,
you throw your whole heart and soul into it.
It just doesn't seem fair that everything you love and everything that makes you
who you are and gives you your identity is also stealing your mind.
But that's why people respect fighters.
You know?
That's why we look up the fighters and that's why fighters are lot of peoples'
heroes.
But there's a price.
Well I taught.
So combat sports,
there are two parts of your body that are not made for combat sports.
No matter what your knees and your head,
you know,
I thought you're going to say your Dick and your boss and your boss Dick in your
brain.
It's a bath to contact the back is worse because they can fix the knees.
If they can do some pretty good fixing as the nannies,
they can basically fix it,
fix everything except your brain when it's science these days almost there's
some backstory is really not an issue cause a bad point.
Always the first to go though,
aren't you?
Now your brain for sure.
It goes before everything is well,
your knees Kango early,
but they can fix them and make them better than they were before.
As long as you don't have too much meniscus.
Cartilage damage.
And now even then I lead,
they're generating the regenerating cartilage with these stem cell tree.
Crazy.
Yeah.
And this is like what we have now.
What's it gonna be like five years.
And I agree.
They all said they have a scanned percentage though of Devede scaffolding now
that they allows them to regrow a meniscus.
I want her to have to take a cadaver.
I think it's an artificial meniscus.
It's something that they create.
It's like a,
I think it's like they take the,
Oh shit this,
this fight is getting crazy.
Johnson just hit Rochelle with a bottle of a right hand.
Now he's got them down on the ground.
I wonder what percentage of NFL football players have had a knee surgery.
Knee surgery.
Yeah,
I mean a ton.
It's 90% they're getting hit in the knees though.
Well they took away chop blocking.
Like you can't tack out the knees.
There's no chop looking.
There's certain rules they put in but you know scramble.
Crazy shit happens.
Just like sometimes guys don't mean to punch the guy in the back of the head.
Shit ass crazy shit happens.
And that happens in football too.
Well and then it fell analogous is running fucking 30 yards runs of four,
three and the 40 quiet,
quiet,
gnarly as fuck.
So not so crazy to think of how fucking powerful these guys are and love it.
It's insane.
I couldn't stop staring at Alden Smith.
He was in just a pair of shorts looking at the,
um,
the other we're talking about on a TV last night.
Is that the guy you were talking about?
Um,
the guy who got his super athlete.
You got cut by the point.
I know she got in,
had a science night,
is released him,
but I can't talk about it,
but I have some shit that I know because I talked to Tarik.
He said coach.
Yeah.
And uh,
you'll see he's okay.
He's fine.
I love that guy.
It's a bummer.
Oh Jesus.
Look at this fucking Taco one.
I didn't watch close enough.
I didn't watch close enough for you there.
Anytime.
A heavyweight fight the decision.
No one's a fan,
believe me.
Oh,
that was wild fight,
man.
That was a wildfire definition.
Wilds different.
But yeah,
that was kind of fun to watch.
Yeah.
I want say while it's not going to grade this,
my God,
just say it's not wild.
Gentlemen.
Have their bout his name rather is being rather,
I'm judgmental,
judgmental and eat.
Eating for sure.
Yep.
We tried to do this.
Where'd you get the punches and Chris?
Yeah,
we can hear that shit loud in class dude.
Yeah these are,
these are good microphone.
So this isn't your set up.
These are real microphones.
This is all high tech Shit.
Yup.
Can still hear this microphones that we can get.
There'll be even more more.
They'll catch me even more.
The atmosphere,
the room in this.
But I think this is the right,
this is my favorite studio man.
I've ever been.
I love this studio.
Let me too,
I've got to replace this bitch in the new spot.
I was Tony because Tony guys a little bit off here cause we're renegotiating a
contract with Fox and that the,
you know the heads of Fox,
the suits,
they hate the kid in big brown that they love our numbers.
So you know they were working.
No they hate you and you're paranoid.
You know,
they don't know that well but they listen to it cause like what's going on?
We're getting all these comments and the me and Brian talking about Dick Jokes
and chicken and chicken,
right.
Corporate.
And that's not very corporate out.
We tell him what they tell him.
He goes,
is there any way you guys can talk less about ticks?
Is there way?
No.
Probably not.
We're too young to do that.
I'm 40.
Well here's the thing man,
once they start asking you,
it's just never going to stop.
No,
no.
That was the term though.
Cause we came to an agreement and they go,
we're gonna let you keep doing your thing cause you have great numbers.
You guys do that and now we're,
now we're going to do,
we just signed this deal to do a digital shows of Brian and myself.
Like Robin big.
What's Robin big?
Uh,
but basically like,
um,
how would you describe Robin Big Jamie,
what is it?
It's a,
it's a reality show,
but like that you,
you do stupid stuff like Brian and I are going to attempt naked and afraid when
we go.
Go fucking out in the woods button.
Aka you do this.
Why didn't you guys talk to me first?
It's an extension of the podcast is two or three minutes.
Sketchy.
Yeah.
Like sketching naked and afraid for two or three minutes.
Brendon,
how to be an actor.
Your podcast numbers are undeniable.
No they can't,
but you're getting 50 cents a fucking gas.
All these different people,
you guessed.
It's undeniable.
So once that happens,
there's really nothing they can do.
They fucked up.
It's like what happened when the Internet,
they would,
the government I'm sure would not like everyone have access to all the
information in the world,
but the door's open.
There's nothing they could do about it.
Now.
Once it gets open like that,
that's what it is.
They were there.
Yeah.
They were cool about it.
They're just like,
hey man,
is there,
what is the kings of Leon?
Is that a band?
David done shit in a wild though.
Things are rough in Nashville.
That's if that's the star there.
That's it.
It's all,
it's there.
That's it.
No Big Brown.
None.
The audience and the smiling,
no one's invited.
Big Round fight.
Invited the big browns on that house.
Their latest album has a really good song called wait for me.
Yeah,
most of the album.
Not that really into,
not my cup of tea from me.
I'm worried if I shut the UFC event there and put me in the nose bleeds and be
like,
you got to wear all this Reebok.
Lucky for you.
You know somebody would tickets.
Oh Vince,
same pru.
They're not going to do that to you man.
It wouldn't put you in a Lowe's.
Please listen,
you're an ally and an asset for the UFC.
You're a huge UFC fan.
It's just huge fan.
But someone like Fox,
they're going to have a problem with what you're doing because it's so
unconventional.
And if you say something ridiculous,
they're the ones who are going to get blamed for it.
Who let these fucking guys get on the Fox network.
That's also why our numbers are so big.
Cause cause,
cause I don't sugarcoat things and I realize I'm gonna get in trouble.
This is why I told you you guys shouldn't be on anybody's network.
I know you've always said that you don't want to send a Fox,
don't censor us.
And they're like,
cool,
keep doing your thing.
As soon as your numbers drop,
we're gonna kill you and you shouldn't have a contract with anybody.
There's no need.
There's no need for anybody to have anything in writing that connects you and
them to what you guys are doing.
Well,
you guys are doing is you guys for just no need.
Like it's not,
you're not gaining anything by being affiliated with someone.
In fact,
you're losing money.
You're losing money,
you're losing control and you're losing your mind because you're having to have
these conversations with.
They tell you not to talk about Dick.
You shouldn't be connected to anybody.
It should be only you.
This is 2015 you don't need that Rhonda Commercial.
Another one.
Unstoppable.
She's beyond Bruce Lee's.
Come on.
Ticketless Bruce Lee never got this big.
Oh,
real quick.
If he didn't die,
but they wouldn't be doing commercial.
Fuck Bruce Lee about that.
Sure.
What?
Joe Rogan,
Eddie Bravo.
Brian said he could beat up Bruce Lee.
I believe I could beat him in a fight.
He's dead.
See I'm being serious.
Well you weighed 35 pounds and you're at least one 40.
Hey man,
70 bro.
There's also the possibility that you were some sort of a taekwondo fighter.
Yeah,
man.
That's why I'm buying a shirt.
So I don't know.
I don't like the way you just implied that maybe I wasn't.
By the way you said that,
because he took a sip of wine in a very,
I'm so glad there's at least one video of me knocking somebody out on line one.
Thank you.
I'm like something so many fought some something cause otherwise it sounds like
there weren't,
oh hey mom has them.
She'll,
she'll send me to say that.
Cause I used to ask him for
the longest time,
I was like,
Shit.
But I experienced his turning side of cake,
like firsthand.
Uh,
we'd be in his garage and he'd be,
he'd be kip murdering the bathroom and I didn't know if that was normal.
I'm like,
is that normal?
Normal?
So this is what happened.
I'd go to,
uh,
back to Jujitsu school.
And that was one bag.
It was a Jujitsu John Jackman Machado Academy.
There's one kicking bag that's heavy on the bottom.
It's not even hanging from the ceiling.
And,
uh,
and,
and in Jujitsu there's always karate,
black belt,
taekwondo,
black belt in Jujitsu.
It's very,
very common that these black belts from the striking discipline's a traditional
martial arts or are taking Jujitsu.
So I didn't know if he was like,
it was normal.
So I would have a guy who kicked the bag,
a black belt,
and I,
and I said,
throw it turning sidekick.
Let me see what it feels like,
or it looks like.
And then he throw it.
Then Joe would come and fucking throw it and everybody would just stand back and
say,
dude,
he's 40 shows tap and 48 years old,
no one in the back.
No one else kicked the bed at first to be trying to fuck me.
I go,
okay.
So it's real.
And then I would get,
I would get into that.
I,
I would,
uh,
there was one time he went to go get his car and talked about this.
Okay,
well we didn't talk about this March and I grabbed that cards.
Amazing.
By the way,
I'm sorry to interrupt you.
I that cards amazing.
Anthony Johnson.
Jim Man.
Ooh.
When asleep son page.
I said girl verse Alex Chan mean we were seeing with the [inaudible] me and Joe
and mark they'll go out to and delegate out to is saying that he,
I,
you may laugh,
but I spent a long time kicking and I spent a long time.
I'm really good guys who could kick really hard.
I've never seen anybody kicked the way he does.
That's where it says 48 years old and marked in the [inaudible].
I said,
I can't hold pads because my forearms,
I couldn't sign.
It was trying to sign checks.
He goes,
my hands were shaking too much after holding fucking pads for you as you were
kicking him.
I,
when I saw that Instagram personally I,
I've spent a long time around good kickers and trying to kick really well
myself.
I've never seen him in a kick like that.
I never said this dudes,
you kick whiter than me.
We should watch videos of Melvin Manhoef Columbine.
But you're not that far behind,
Bro.
You're really not.
You're not that far behind all I it anybody that holds pads for him and it's
crazy.
He's,
everyone says the same thing.
Holy Goddamn shitty.
Yet he's got,
it's every strike.
It isn't just the turning psyche.
It's every goddamn strike.
It's just leg stuff.
I just grew up doing it,
man.
Taekwondo gives you this weird weird,
I it for a long time.
I don't have that.
Well,
I have a loose like a snap to my hips.
They,
they,
I don't tighten them up.
It's all loosened to the end and then in the end you're digging in [inaudible]
we have the pick shit.
Fucking love me some vehicles,
man.
I thought it was one podcast where we just went balls deep in these pickles.
That's those Grillo's pickles though.
These are like regular fucking store bought.
Pickles are really good.
They're okay,
but Grillo's this shit.
Okay.
Those are the shit.
I think if more guys did yoga,
I think yoga would help your cakey yoga.
Yoga is the shit dude.
And I think stretch,
stretching and flexibility like Eddie Bravo's guard is like the one of the most
preposterous guards you can get caught in.
It's just his leg dexterity is ridiculous.
It's so unusual.
And a lot of that is because of his flexibility is flexibility.
It's crazy.
And I see guys,
it's cranes.
Duty is not an always says stop,
please stop.
Because you're way more flexible.
You way more flexible in certain ways than me and I'm very flex in illusion.
No it's not.
But I've seen people trying to emulate what he does.
But you don't have the flexibility.
Yeah,
they did can't.
They don't have the dexterity.
You don't have flexibility and it makes such a giant difference.
It's those numbers that you get in.
It's just those numbers in the idea of what you're trying to do.
And then there's all the physical shit cause some people are just born with
different bones.
Yeah,
they just built,
some people are born like Hydra Gracie,
these long ass fucking arms.
They can just cinch Darcy's in from anywhere long triangles that can get both of
your fucking arms trapped in like an a dead orchard.
They can do things with your body if you have these long bodies that you can't
do.
But then there's these Paul Horace bodies.
Plus you've got this goddamn gorilla.
I'm lucky.
Strike that guy.
I feel like I'm you.
That's what it's like.
I stand next to him.
Dark Guy.
Yeah.
I have a beautiful expressive Balis feel like a Clod.
Always feel like an extra y.
I see a big ass fucking arm over there.
You're looking at that arm?
No,
seriously.
I'm Brian.
You should lift right.
Here's the body of hermits.
A frog.
Hey Bro.
What are you talking about?
Jeans
flex for sure.
Show him the guys.
I'm relaxing my shit right now.
I'm relaxed.
His Shins.
He Kermit the frog.
My legs are way bigger than that.
So funny
the frog.
So Ronnie,
what size?
All the way down.
All their Kermit the frog here.
Good.
Currently fraud.
That's not
a bad shot too.
That was actually her
arms.
Just like cripes to stream pipe cleaners.
So silly and funny.
He's like the perfect reference that is like,
seriously are you going to make fun of a dude's arm curry curve into frogs are
currently
take offense.
I'm pissed now.
Thank you brother.
Thank you man.
Jesus Christ.
Fucking Instagram posts that you and I both posted you.
You posted a caption with it.
There's a dude who suck in.
Then I sent that to my brother Eddie Bravo.
Probably the best captured on his Eddie Brown says,
when you partied and Rodman has the last rock
go king.
The reason why it came up to me it was because the guy has Kermit the frog
buddy.
We were talking about how this guy's like so meek.
He's probably like only like three feet tall and he's just like used to being
humiliated,
suck their toes and Camp God has aren't women.
Dude.
Come on man,
dude,
and this dude is just deep throating these toes.
I sent it to you.
Then I found it that judge Joseph [inaudible].
Everyone did.
That's probably how Dennis Rodman's feet actually
bravo on Instagram is not you.
He's now the reality
following someone named Lindsey Sturge.
I don't know on Instagram,
I dunno.
There's someone named Lindsey on sex crimes and must be an Eddie Bravo.
Thank God she took my shit so I had to do that douchey thing by saying the real
raw as I feel really do.
She won't take your shit.
I thought that I originally,
I just thought that's what you're supposed to do.
If like
this is
real fucking fun.
Somebody told me,
somebody told me once that if a girl has a second toe that's bigger than the big
toe,
that she's undoubtedly free no matter what she tells you.
She could tell you she goes to church.
The a freak like
girl.
That's not across fight.
Not a girl's foot.
You right in that it might be a girl split.
I don't think so.
It might be like so what's that of time possible?
No,
no.
Gallium Gabrielle Reece who shake go chicken.
Okay,
here we go.
Rebecca Lobos,
Derek Brunson.
Sam Alvin is a good God damn about Sam.
Sam Ma Alvey on the ultimate fighter season 14 I was a guest coach on there and
he drove me fucking nuts.
I didn't think would make you shit because he quit nonstop all the time.
Quiz.
Yeah.
And they already quit sparring and seems to be going rafting.
He just stopped and then be like,
oh I'm hurt and would sit out all the time.
Nervous man.
Oh Shit.
He's a tough fight.
Brunson has really good kicks,
man.
He uh,
caught Yoel Romero with a switch kick to the head and that's when I realized
like,
what a freak you,
oh,
we're marrow is.
Cause Yoel Romero took it right on the neck and just stunned them for a second
and then just went right back to his normal.
Have a fight coming up.
Did he sign anything?
I do not know.
That's a good question.
I think he's hoping he's wide breaking his threat in many ways.
Eol No,
I think Rockhold is,
I think it's the greatest fight.
Middleweight his career out of your mind.
It's,
well he's not out of his mind for sure.
It's a good fight,
Brian.
No,
you're wrong.
They're both in their prime.
Could have easily been monsters in the crime.
You gotta tell me how you watch him go through Leo Machida.
Like fucking hot butter and you don't want to see Rockhold fight.
What to guess why I thought I actually thought let me cheat a one that last
round or at least was awesome.
You got the wrong fight.
You have the wrong fight.
Fuck you.
Talking called destroy.
Not talking about machinery.
It either way lost either way.
Lost that.
Well Machida and Weidman,
handsome,
great exchanges and there was one exchange,
particularly when Machida poured it on,
but Whiteman,
why Miss Really fucking durable.
There was no,
his legs never went.
Yes,
he got tagged with some shots,
but it was never like,
oh my God,
he's gone.
He's gone out.
It wasn't like he,
he's a beast.
I what I'm trying to say is I,
I think that y'all Romero is a bigger threat to why man,
his cardio is going to be an issue.
Well,
his cardio is definitely going to be an issue,
but I don't think he's a bigger threat.
I think he's a huge threat.
I think they're both huge threats.
It's like different [inaudible] going off different threats.
Tough.
He's not.
He's just swinging for the fences.
All these 900 now.
I'll be better close his mouth though,
but see,
this is one way you should relax.
Relax.
You got wobbled relaxed,
but he can move better than this.
It guys relaxed.
Yeah,
for she was relaxed here and not just fucking teeing off with 100% he's wasting
energy.
I agree.
If he was more fishing,
more shots for Roche.
This is what I want to see though.
I want to see guys like this,
but for him as a fighter,
he could do better.
He stopped it.
Stopped.
It stopped.
That was good.
Yeah.
That's a good stoppage.
I love that for him as I am too,
but if he just took it down a notch with the wildness and was more accurate
control or compose more control,
that's expense.
It is experience.
We've all,
we've all been in that situation where especially if you're angry at somebody
and you yourself chasing them
emotion,
you bring an emotional brushes.
We have enough smart guys like that.
Let me every now and then can I get like God,
it's going to go out there or not.
You're getting that until you get the higher levels.
I want to see that.
I want to see him develop to the highest skill level possible.
I think Derrick Brooks,
it's a bad enough that's hurting guy and like say being controlled and then
timing it for the exact time.
We can't have one fucker that goes out there and throws bombs and I'm not
looking for unique individuals that you know don't reach their potential.
We're looking for everybody to be as good as they fight.
Like this should be 50 50 should be trying like it shouldn't go five and ten
eight years.
Here's a perfect example.
You want to get Jay check when she had Jessica Pinay hurt in the same type of
situation.
She didn't do this.
Okay.
Everything.
She did look crisp and controlled.
How can was way more devastating?
Love fighters was more devastated,
but they can't all be like,
dad,
can we have crazy motherfuckers like this every now and then gets a higher level
where this doesn't work.
Just,
he just needs to get better.
That's all it is.
He's really good,
really good to take him away from me,
but it's not even a matter of fact that he can't perform the punches and kicks
correctly because obviously he can.
It's just a matter of composure while executing.
Like I've guaranteed if you got Derek Brunson and you were like,
if Anthony hard doc was working pads with him and you've got to see him throw
some combinations,
he would.
It look smooth as butter instead of while he's just fighting emotionally there.
I've been there man.
And he broke the dude.
He did it.
I mean he really did do it.
He broke up and he beat him down.
You're going to get to a certain level and it happened with me when I thought
Ben Rothwell,
I threw a spinning back elbow rocked them and I rushed in like just like he was
doing and Rotha went,
oh,
cool story.
He hurt through a class,
torque fights over.
If I had been more controlled,
smart,
calculated.
You want me to start?
Laski did actually with a,
with Travis Brown.
Yeah.
He kind of fight smart.
He kind of kept waiting,
caught the cop bad,
got caught hard.
He got her lost keys also,
you know,
he's got a former world champions,
a lot of experiences.
A lot of guys,
when we get rocked like that,
especially,
you know you will,
you want to get in and get it.
You're like,
oh,
he's hurt.
I'm going to jump on them.
Right?
That's one of the guys most dangerous.
Let's get this.
Carl's Jr is selling a beef burger with no steroids.
That's what it said.
It said,
no snow.
Carl's Jr sign Ronda Rousey.
Damn.
Who didn't.
Right?
Rhonda Rousey is going to be so God damn rich when she retires.
It's going to be preposterous as she's already pretty rich.
She's already pretty rich,
but the amount of Richie's going to be shitting me like Oprah rich.
She's not a materialistic person at all.
It doesn't mean what if you guys got back together again?
It might be a good move for you,
right?
[inaudible]
I give it.
I did her a favor,
man.
I'm not the guy for the job.
I'm just not man.
Not Man enough or woman there.
I'm too much.
I'm too Miami.
Yes,
she needs,
she needs the guy who's going to take a back seat.
That's not me.
She also needs a guy who's gonna say yes ma'am.
Yes ma'am.
Really?
Well.
She's surrounded by it.
You know,
she's so successful.
She's surrounded by people that wore spur and go,
yes,
that's a great idea.
But when I went,
I don't think that's a good idea.
Now I'm a hater.
No,
no,
no.
I have.
I have no financial gain from you.
I don't want,
I don't need anything from him.
I've learned everything myself.
I don't think we should have this conversation.
I got a respect for her.
She can't defend herself.
Started me.
You got me on it already.
Start Trumpster the time you said get back.
Apologize.
I'll respect to respect to too,
and you know what?
We've been talking nothing but good shit about his tone.
I think all of us,
I think that I fucked that.
We've talked about this before.
You kind of have to be out of your mind to be as good as shoes you have to be.
You know?
And I think that she would probably admit it as quickly as anybody.
And I think that in that position that she's in,
when you are that powerful and that strong and this shuts a show,
such a shining star man,
this,
the finding a guide to match that with you,
like finding a guy that you know that you mesh with perfectly,
it's going to be bullied,
struggle.
That's the balance,
right?
Like people who are that great to me.
Tough.
And your personal life,
man.
What do I always say?
I wish I was more bat shit crazy.
I'd be a way better fighter fucking God.
You know?
Nice.
If I weren't so nice and friendly and creative,
I'd be a way better fire.
And then the opposite like Bobby Lee,
you know,
it's very hard for him to find a woman that can,
can control him and dominate him correctly.
Who?
Bobby Lee.
Because Lee is the opposite.
Bobby's like this like really small,
feeble guy who's afraid of everything.
So he's got to find the right woman for that situation.
It might be a match for most women.
It doesn't jam up.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Yes.
Most women want to be like,
yeah,
taking care of like throw me against the wall.
Bobby Lee's I told me against the wall.
You know what I'm saying?
But he's funny.
So this is funny.
Helps out man.
Try to find
the right person for the job.
That really,
that's really what's up.
You know.
And the funny shit is like Jay Leno and I were having this conversation about it
named namedrop watch it.
Uh,
we were talking about this guy that showed up.
It is a studio once and just started asking questions about some actress and
said,
do you think I could meet her?
Because if I've met her,
I'm pretty sure that she would know that,
uh,
that I'm the one and he's like,
Jesus Christ.
Like,
cause you,
you imagine being a famous woman,
have a bunch of dummies out there.
The thing they got to you that they could be the one and then they just go,
I go,
just go to [inaudible] Rhonda.
She has all these keyboard warriors jacket off to her all the time it got.
If I could just get in front of her man,
I'm the guy for the job.
Just smell her ass.
Enjoy that.
Like is just drink or bath water man.
I would fucking,
oh shit.
Peniel dairy.
Newish.
Michael Shannon's the bell on the slide down.
Do you want to bet on it?
I like both.
These guys I would never bet against.
I would never ask you to bet.
I'm excited about this fight,
but if you pick one,
I'll pick the other.
I got della Rouche.
Okay.
And he's under Doug [inaudible].
It's not Delaware.
No,
no fuck up.
Name from time to time.
Most certainly don't want to bet against Ben Neil dairy,
which cause I'm a big fan,
but then we're just,
just for the fun of things.
Favor of just sport and fun or dinner.
You want bet dinner.
Okay,
thanks brother.
I'm taking the under dog dog.
I think he's a very skilled fighter.
I liked the way you fight too.
I also like would Hofeld cord Darrow's done,
man.
I was cornering.
Uh,
Brian [inaudible] the kid who's tearing up in the UFC right now.
I was caught him on a low level show in La and dare you,
she was in the back warming up cause he was the main event and I was watching
him hit mitts and I was like,
Holy Fuck,
really?
Who is that guy in TCD was like,
oh that guy's the next big thing.
So I went and talked to him.
I saw his fight and I'm like,
dude,
what's your deal?
It's like,
man,
I'm just,
I'm just trying to get better,
blah blah blah.
I'm like,
Oh,
what's your background?
And he starts telling me like,
Jujitsu is my passion and he's this worldclass Jujitsu guy.
But I saw him just wrecked some dude on the feet.
I was like,
you're good at Jitsu.
He goes,
yeah man,
it's my thing.
I was like,
holy fuck.
He's very good at you.
Just see his fight with Jim Miller.
Phenomenally dominate Jim Miller and dominates
ground man
dominates him.
Crazy shit man.
Crazy man.
It's crazy.
Dominate genes.
Crazy ground.
Your fucking pretty good.
Yeah.
Jim Miller is tough as fuck man.
They don't get any tougher and he's a black belt in judo.
He submitted that Brazilian world world champ nearby Armbar.
Yeah,
yesterday.
Jim Miller is one of the noise.
Yes.
Yeah.
He's a,
he's elite,
very elite on the ground.
He also submitted a Charles Olivera and I'm in a leg lock.
He's elite.
He's one of those guys that are always watched fight and I always appreciate his
fights is fantastic,
but I'm always like,
man,
how many more of these it's got to have in them.
It's a bummer,
right?
Yeah.
Because that style is just so taxing.
Miller was just fucking super aggressive.
Again,
speaking of that style,
we had a buddy,
I won't mention names,
fight in the UFC and his style was kind of like that Leonard Garcia style,
and I talked to him on the phone and could not understand them,
literally cannot understand them and I go,
what are you doing these days,
man?
I'm just,
I'm just
to teach in a little box and then I'm working at this school.
Did you know Shane Mosley's fighting soon?
Shane Mosley is fighting Ricardo [inaudible].
That's such a bummer.
Have you ever met Mosley?
Know what?
I've seen him talk hunch drunk.
So I just punched trunk.
But how about the fact that his body seems to have deteriorated like he shrank
his buck is muscle definition has done.
He was on.
Um,
there was,
uh,
one of those shows that white wine get that fucking shit up with that white
shit.
Where's the Red Gun?
I'm a man,
Bro.
I'm gonna drink.
I mean,
if it's all we have,
hey,
what's up with the red right there?
Whoa.
Don't put that Angel Piss in here.
Hey Jill.
That's hilarious.
I'm not red dog.
All right man.
I'm a fan of this.
Wait,
well does that guy fucking dude,
two men.
But Neil diary should a smart feed.
Very calculated.
Waking on the ground.
Man looks at his ground game.
Nasty fucking submissions.
Michael Johnson.
Michael Johnson has been sparring on a regular basis with Nikki holds skin.
Nikki holes can retrain it with a black ceiling.
It's,
there are some great videos that I'm going to war.
They'd been sparring exclusively down there.
Jesus,
Nikki holds gives also been working out with his ducks to kickboxing coach.
The kickboxing coach for a whole skin is showing them combinations that they use
trouble cause he's getting the faculty to pick it up like that.
He's picking it up.
His sparring sessions had been fucking legendary down.
They were the whole skin hope of it.
Well no,
there's some videos of him getting it.
There's one of them and get rocked holes can caught him with a left hook
already.
It might be a good tee shirt.
That's a great sign.
The kid,
you were the girl with the frog clean flippers.
I always be as miss piggy.
I always thought that Dutch kickboxing,
like the Anthony Hardonk style,
I always thought that was the Dutcher's version of [inaudible] Thai.
But hanging out with Anthony,
he's telling me he's giving me the history and has,
it's really has nothing to do with them.
Wait Times more karate,
karate base.
It's karate base.
But they did incorporate some of the Thai techniques and they definitely did
incorporate like,
but they,
they use is more like a showed aecon or um,
uh,
not show to conduct Kojo rule.
You're like one of those hard styles.
He said the main difference is the footwork and we tie,
he kind of just plod forward.
There's no footwork in with,
with,
with what they do.
It's like Mecina there's a lot of footwork and out and you just don't stand
there and take shots.
Yeah.
They also have this fucking hardstyle man.
It's a hard style.
There's the Holland style of kickboxing.
They had some,
some,
some innovations of their own too.
Like you know,
that combination that everybody calls the Duchy that left hook to the body and
the right leg kick behind it.
That's something that's like really classic to more Thai.
But,
but the Dutch really took it to another level.
They throw like boxing style combinations that the,
uh,
the,
the Thai guys didn't.
And then when,
um,
uh,
Ramon Dekkers went over there and fought the ties,
he is a beast.
Oh my God.
He was fun to watch monster.
And he fought the ties at their weight.
It wasn't like Cayman or lot.
These other guys who were like bigger guys from Holland are huge.
You know,
the average height of a gynecologist,
six feet tall and a woman.
The both Overeems or from
Peter Wirtz.
Anthony said he said that a low level boxer can beat a low level Dutch kickboxer
but uh,
an elite Dutch kickboxer will always beat an elite boxing cause they will never
withstand the leg.
Dutch,
he's right
at the head.
We know how to count.
But especially especially with boxing gloves on,
especially with boxes.
No,
I agree.
I just gets way trickier when you have little gloves.
Right.
That's why you see Joe Schilling got knocked.
The stances difference gloves sneak through for sure.
Working on take downs.
We were talking about the difference between boxing and the Dutch style
kickboxing.
He was,
he really was talking about boxing.
Like it was primitive.
Like there's so many things that you do wrong and boxing that when the legs are
involved,
we'll get,
and Joe Schilling got knocked out and Gloria meant in Beltour but uh,
a great kick boxer fighting a guy was a karate guy was a fucking tough karate
guy though.
This stuff,
dude,
I can't get enough of boxing now.
I watch every fucking boxing match.
Did you see,
did you say yes lord.
He's damn,
he's based man.
He hits so hard.
He's a monster and it's so fucking hot.
Or You have the time or you're single.
No,
I have a girl there.
They're huge on Saturday nights though.
Bitches now time for the fucking,
you have fee and you're such a UFC x but you know,
every goddamn fight of,
you know,
record a minute.
Holy Shit.
It's all so much fights twice every week.
It just depends.
Most fight to watch important ones you watch twice important ones.
Yeah.
So Kovalev is Kovalev is just such a smooth box.
Sam Fight.
Andre Ward.
I think that'd be,
that's a phenomenal fight.
Andre Ward need to do something.
I mean,
he's recovering from shoulder surgery.
He is,
but he just fought.
He just slapped me versus time.
Yeah,
they brought him up.
I Dunno.
I feel like Andre Ward,
I think he's the best fighter right now is his very soul.
Good man.
When you do with a cover that that'd be a really white,
such a good fight.
He's black,
but he's a gold medal stand and his dad was white.
His father,
his mother was black.
He said half a hundred word.
Yeah,
he's so,
he's so good,
man.
Yeah.
Cool.
Cause an Alpha an owl boxes on ESPN.
NBC.
It's so dope,
man.
Really?
Yes.
Wow.
I'd really like to see that fight that,
that'd be ridiculous.
A lot of really good fights in boxing right now.
You know the middleweight division,
it's heat can add a Canelo Alvarez,
Gennady Golovkin and Alvarez is going fight 'em Cody's face.
Cody,
Miguel,
Cotto Thurman.
God Damn Garcia.
Like a girl right now.
Bought boxes with a lot of lists.
Like what the fuck?
I love boxing.
It's fun.
It's fun to watch.
Yeah.
Kickboxing is more fun to me.
I'm a big fan of lion fight,
man.
I love what I love.
When I fight.
Where do you see that tie on access,
TV,
real moy time.
Fifth time bomb man.
Tim time mom to do cheese.
Now she gets into MMA.
It's going to be trouble man.
With her stand up.
Oh yeah,
our standups now.
She's kind of talked a little
shit to Yolanda.
She has.
I'm a festive time basic.
She said she thought her standup was basic tip time bond.
Yeah.
She's a cutie too man too.
I saw he admits and blackouts and I was like,
good Lord.
She's legit.
You know what?
I'm looking forward to you man.
I'm looking forward to some of these small two girls getting into MMA.
Like Jujitsu world champions.
Hira.
Yeah,
Kiera fighting.
He's traveling on.
She is.
If she got to,
she would be fighting one 15 she got in there.
Oh my God.
She's like five seven one 15 I think she weighs Kira.
Kira,
Gracie,
Gracie too.
She had a baby too.
She's 10
and 10 10 and she will straight Armbar your Dick Bryan strangle,
hundred percent she will arm,
Barnes,
shuck and faith.
Yeah,
man.
She's,
I mean,
she's know Bruce Lee,
but fight,
I love cheese.
Oversleep,
man.
You'd have your hands full.
Michael Johnson getting done.
Fuck yet is this is a great fighter.
You do.
We have a bet on the main event.
OSB.
You're,
you're really,
damn,
I've OSPI too,
but I'll bet I'll bet off.
Taste.
No Way.
I'll take lower just for the bet.
How much,
what do you want?
Something to Glover's a tough fight for hell.
Yeah,
it's a tough fight.
They think it's,
but if the glow over before he fought Jon Jones,
do you think Glover has had too many tough fights?
There's tough.
It'll date.
Find my boy.
Not just hasn't been training,
right.
He's doing something wrong.
Eddie.
Eddie can't really bet on this because Osp is his boy.
So this is one of those the favorite.
Yeah,
but Eddie,
Eddie camp,
he can't,
you know,
she's so hot here,
but even if he wasn't
he,
he's very good at the twister and he's a,
well,
he's not going to twist her 10th planet clover.
He's not going to tech twist twister,
glow over.
That ain't happening.
Trust me.
This
is phenomenal.
Athlete,
man.
He's,
that's great.
Yeah.
Okay,
here we go,
and he is,
Jujitsu is very dangerous.
Let's bet on it then.
Oh my God,
you guys are getting 500 500 deal too.
I love it cause you find the last band.
They covered it.
Even honey,
that's the best way.
Just keep doing it back and forth and just keep a tab on.
We got get paid.
We'll keep a tab going
dark.
It gets dark and we have to have a meeting and shame
me man.
It's 30,000 with just gimme five right now and shut the fuck up.
Instead of me giving you five,
I'll bet you five on the next [inaudible] when we call it.
If
you lose and fuck you lose a thumb
back room back there.
I'll bet you a thumb.
Michael Johnson,
here we go.
Now let me ask you,
this wears dirty was from were originally.
Do we know?
I used to know,
I can't remember right somewhere and like or by genre or something.
Her book sex.
It's from the steps somewhere.
This is the best fight on the car,
I think would be good to get rebounds on girl.
Now she's a dear.
Lovely.
I want to kick her out of bed for crackers.
Which one?
That ring card girl.
Her name Christine is kindness.
This guy reminds me of that.
Very nice ladies.
[inaudible] garden was Sassy kind of thing.
He's Kinda,
he's Kinda relaxed.
So what happened with dairy?
You Shit,
I need to watch that fight with SLAs.
Loss,
right?
In Ramsey.
Yeah,
me too.
I had no idea.
But that's just shows too.
Anybody can get caught.
Anybody can get caught in any given time.
You Zig when you should've zagged.
He has competence now though.
You know he's ripped off a couple big wins.
So as Michael Johnson confidence,
fuck dude does a good job of keeping his chin tucked.
He doesn't keep his hands up high,
but he keeps his chin tucking pretty good.
See how it is from our end.
Thank you Jamie.
Powerful young Jamie.
But she always keeping his chin tucked here.
But I bet you he is a Syrian from uh,
from Iran.
Why do I know that?
Did you know that?
You know,
I know that she made because he's a Christian and so if he's a Christian in
Iran,
he's probably an Assyrian,
powerful knowledge of the world.
Brian won't drop some World Shit on,
you know,
man,
I don't want to have it when I guessed all their nationalities.
That's it.
That was amazing.
Main a coffee shop.
No one spoke English.
You start saying you're from Afghanistan,
you're from Belarus,
you're from Croatia.
And I was like,
this was on drugs and all the girls started clapping.
And I go in here from Turkey through to see that HQ group.
I ran the fuck's wrong with you.
Come on brother.
You know I got the guns.
I got no
knowledge.
I'm fucking getting pumped right now.
Last time we'd rather,
I'm still hiring.
Nope.
Okay.
Right here.
I'm good.
That was very,
I went to a different planet.
That was a great answer.
I'm not,
I'm not a seasoned leader.
You see that Hbo special about Iran where uh,
you can die if you're gay,
but if you have a sex change to let you live.
Yes.
I didn't see that.
So all these,
all these gators,
you're supposed to take advantage of science.
Science has never been something that was,
I had a problem with you going to take advantage of.
Yeah,
but what did you say?
They're trying to kill you if you're gay.
Oh,
that sounds very science
behind that.
By the,
by the way,
there's a bunch of transvestites.
I just wished there were like,
dude,
it's a shitload of Caitlyn Jenner.
Like they're not pretty.
It was either that or die.
No,
it's it actually though.
Or Jay leaves or not believe it or not,
they
say that,
but there are gay communities in Iran and places and like anywhere else,
they're kind of left alone.
What's going on here?
There's a commercial that's going on while the show fight is going on for a
movie.
They just showed a commercial in the corner movie,
like full videos and shit.
You know how much they had to pay for that shit.
I don't,
I've never done crazy VIP treatment.
I am not.
I'm not understanding of that.
Yeah.
I'm not appreciating that.
Especially these two.
This is not just fighters.
It's not just words like Monday night football,
mark it on the bottom,
which is just show naked chicks.
Just going to distract too.
What if the renewals by Reebok
whole,
yeah,
just a girl naked,
throwing a monster energy drink down or positive.
Oh Jesus.
This chasm.
No joke.
He you're running your parents a little bill Hicks.
Bit about that.
Bill Hicks got a great joke about advertisers.
If they could do what they wanted to do,
you just see a girl and you'd focus on her and he would go down to her pussy
lips.
You'd see she's spreading her fingers,
spreading her pussy and looking you in the eye and it just says drink coke
or drink coke.
Yeah,
snickers.
That great bit.
It's so true.
If they get do it,
that would totally work.
Maybe we turned a lot of women off from coke.
Think if you could do whatever you want,
there's no fricking repercussions called prince assigned.
You're doing right now on the Internet son.
This is true.
That's why Fox is panicking that can't control big brown.
He said
nobody can get into it.
They might pull some JFK shit and the UFC might just snap me out.
Listen,
my,
they're not straight left.
Beautiful timing by Johnson.
Damn.
I missed it.
That was pretty,
oh man.
He's teeing them up to my mom since today's been spiraling.
Hold skin.
He's a fucking animal now.
Darrio field probably sales like there's something going on.
It's like he's hitting the dice.
Told toe,
caught him,
caught him with a nice them.
Try to tell.
Sure.
Mix up the takedowns though.
Huh?
There'll be so flat footed,
right?
Yeah,
but he thinks she just wants to stand with them.
Ooh.
Yikes.
Excuse he's,
I think he's so fucking confident in standup from spar with Holt skin.
Look at this man.
I think as a,
as good an athlete as he is,
he's picking it up at a very high rate.
I agree.
He's got really good training down there in Florida,
Henry,
who have just so fucking clever as a kickboxing coach.
Where's he down?
Tonsil black.
We'll kick.
I'm sure he will.
We might see bowser.
Holy Shit.
Right?
Instant Barboza holy goddamn chefs we owned all.
That's great.
But you know what's the scariest thing?
His switch kick is so,
so fast.
Remember how fast
it was?
Good.
Yeah,
totally.
Filters filter is really good.
Serious.
We'll kick serious karate.
Traditional martial arts telling us with death behind it.
Super complicated.
He's tough as shit.
When when he does switch kick and he caught him in the ribs,
his his side was a lobster red.
I mean it was so,
it was the duck.
A hematoma almost didn't,
didn't miss a beat.
He was protecting it a little bit,
but it took a lot of shots of the legs that cut down his movement and see,
especially in the third row melting off who's very labored in his movement
because of those kicks.
It slowed.
It slowed him down,
but he is tough as fuck.
It's in Barboza.
Holy fucking shit.
That guy muscles on home.
He might be the best kicker in the UFC.
He's scared.
Might be the best character.
Last guy you want to [inaudible] guys with leg kicks.
He stuck two different guys.
Anthony,
hard Dong said Pedis is up there.
Panacea,
but it's a scarier Donald's.
Ronnie has the best case.
He thinks hard to answer.
That motherfucker tend to top out of mother fucking for sure.
Dossiers.
Donald's his game as anybody that's ever lived.
He's amazing game is anybody.
He's so much fun to hang around with too.
I love that guy.
I love him.
Two,
this is a good fight,
but Daria,
she's got to figure out how to get this fucking fight to the ground.
It's hard because right now,
oh,
look at this dairy who she's coming after him now though.
Pressing Daria.
She's not stupid.
It's just that I feel like the level of sparring that Johnson's been getting
such a high level,
it's gonna be hard to take that dude.
Damn man.
You're going to take him.
It's going to be impossible.
Yeah,
he's so quick.
It sprawl so good.
I mean he rested in college,
right?
You know there's good wrestler too.
When he first started fighting in the UFC and the ultimate fighter showed a lot
of wrestling talents.
This is bigger than him.
He looks bigger,
but it doesn't seem to,
he's a long guy,
you know,
but Johnson's thick.
Oh damn diary.
She's no joke.
These guys.
Johnson has like a nice snap to his punches.
He does.
Like,
he's like,
he's,
he's popping in at the end.
No speed man.
But,
and this is the second round is when you start to see these guys slowed down
quite a bit.
You know,
it's a moral good footwork,
Jonathan.
Fuck yeah.
Looking at like Tj Dillashaw except these not switching to oh,
but don't use tried for the fucking neither do nobody looks as good as Tj right
now.
God Damn Tj look good.
And that human looks so good.
Him and Dominic next or what?
Uh,
it depends on where Dominic is that health wise,
you know,
that's the money.
That's the fight.
But he obviously doesn't want to,
um,
to come back too soon.
I mean,
he's already done that a couple of times.
Blown himself out,
fucked his knees up.
And it's just the whole thing.
It's just such a disaster.
I think Tj even said he'd go up to 45 and fight Conor.
Yes,
he did.
Yeah.
But the phenomenal
team,
that would be [inaudible].
That's what he wants.
If Dominic
can't go,
he wants to Connor.
Oh Shit.
Wow.
Don't be crazy to t John Connor though.
He's a lot smaller little dude.
But you know what is luck?
Good luck kid.
And Him and his Jujitsu.
Jujitsu is very good.
I remember back in the day when he was first coming up,
Tj,
I'm like,
that little wrestler has,
he understands that you get to right away.
He's,
he's,
he's young in this game and a lot of wrestlers that takes them years to figure
out.
You got to fall in love with the kids too.
That's such a high stakes gamble though to fight or garlic Connor because Connor
could knock them out like Connor's and shots and Connor's not slow,
not slow with his hands.
You know.
So like when TJ fought Barao Barao the first fight,
he got caught off guard and Tj cracked him.
Nobody expected Tj to be as good as he was.
And after that first round,
that dude was on autopilot and Tj just beat the brakes off of him like a
punching bag.
Just beat his ass.
But the second fight you could see Barao was not the same human being.
He's not the same human being.
He just,
he's not shell shocked.
It could have been extreme loss of confidence is you also have to deal with post
concussion syndrome because that first fight,
he took a fucking beat down.
He took a beating from the first round to the fifth round and especially that
last combination when Ti,
when Tj head kicked him,
come on son.
You're that.
That's terrifying.
Terrifying Shit.
No,
you're right.
So you've got that.
You've got the recovery of that.
We all know someone who's had a fight like that and never really totally
recovered.
So you got that and then you got confidence loss because he was this monster who
hadn't been beaten in nine years and just was running through.
People find a way to feed everybody.
Does it take to get over?
Like your last fight,
you retired,
you got beat down,
you got your title taken,
you never come back.
You're obviously,
you're going to be sad from that like like the next day,
two days later and a week later.
When does it get to a point where that fight doesn't matter the fact that you're
a boxing icon or MMA legend,
you're beyond that last fight.
Like how long does that take you asking the wrong guy cause cause I'm not,
I'm not a legend.
You know some guys look,
no guys ever gone from the ultimate fighter and become as good as Tj did as
quick as Tj did.
Tj is like a real freak and he's also a sponge and he's like,
he's a super nice guy with,
even though Tj is like ultra competitive,
right?
Obviously he's wicked competitive.
He's,
he doesn't have a big ego.
It's weird.
He's like super hard,
hard.
He works hard.
He doesn't have any,
he doesn't have any road bumps.
You know what personality road bumps in some fighters in hand to keep them from
learning.
What's a Bummer Joe?
What is the,
the the kind of the almost want to say the trash truck between Alpha male and
Dwayne.
Now Mike Chapman has goes,
we fucking made Duane Ludwig.
It's true.
No,
they didn't know.
Listen,
they did.
He needed the disciples and he found super athletes that were willing to listen
and it showed what he's capable of,
but also what made him is how good he is at it.
He's one of the best striking coaches I've ever seen for sure and his
relationship with Tj and the progress to Tj is made cement that you,
but you also consider Hockfield Cordaro.
You consider a Duke Roufus.
You could sit there for us as a hobby.
You consider Mike Winkeljohn.
There's a lot of really good striking coaches.
It's really,
a lot of it is dependent upon their students.
Don't think you can say the name,
but,
but Dwayne found a great stable of studs.
That's like every athlete or every trainer's Drey.
It's a collaborative marriage.
It's a symbiotic relationship
taking.
Nobody should be taking credit for anybody,
I think necessarily of team Alpha male.
I'll see.
Dwayne and I are very close.
I'm trying to solve this.
I'm like,
come on.
I'm very close with both of those guys.
I'm very close with Tj.
I'm very close with Danny.
I love Chad Mendez.
I love your writing too.
I love all of that.
Dwayne too and I,
you know on it,
this is like not really talked about very much.
We,
we had one point in time thought about buying their gym,
thought about setting up and on it,
Jim through them and we,
we had considered doing it but we knew that they were having some disputes with
Dwayne and they were trying to sort it out but we were talking about going into
some sort of an a on it partnership with them because we sponsor a lot of those
guys now cam and even language.
You want to start making some more on it.
Jim's and having an audit.
Mma Gym was an idea that we bounced.
We bounced around a few times and I think that when you have a stable full guys
like Chad Mendez,
Lance Palmer,
Tj Dillashaw,
[inaudible],
Ryan motherfucking Faber,
I mean Jesus,
God damn on stairs,
these guys are savages.
And if you get a guy who's as nuts as Duane is,
Dwayne is fucking nuts.
What about training and about like the fanatical approach that he takes to
training guys?
He's obsessed.
He's like a true mad scientist.
I mean hate the day TJ fought Barao.
He and I had lunch and he's,
I,
there was like five or six other people,
they were all laughing,
joking around,
can't wait for the fight today.
And Dwayne is sitting there,
it's like,
what are you gonna do?
Is gonna pick the left and the whole deal about,
well you see broad does these flat foot flat through,
the guy's never going to be gone.
Like TJ.
He goes,
cause you just going to set up these angles and like he went out and did exactly
what Duane said he was gonna do.
But Duane had this maniacal fanatical thing he say is like,
it's like,
uh,
Tj says tapestry.
He's like,
I don't think Tj,
I don't think those guys would be where the APP,
Dwayne exact Duane wouldn't be where he's at without them.
But Danny like Danny Castillo has gotten a lot better.
You see Danny Castillo in his last fight.
He's thrown all these head kicks his foot or it looks amazing and he's learning
from t Janie's learned from Dwayne to it's like well cause he's in Denver with
yes,
exactly.
But that's the point is that like it was just too bad.
Those guys couldn't work it out because that is like literally the dream
relationship.
But they need a mediary even Kamins out now Martin,
Kevin leaving.
But you might just be tired of training.
No,
he no,
he said his family doesn't want to be in tech man.
Him.
That's what he said in the interview.
So now they're looking for other coaches.
They ask,
I think Kenny Florian he get for and considered it apparently.
But he considered,
but I don't think you can do it because all his obligations here,
media and stuff like that.
But can you,
it'd be great.
It would be great.
He's a phenomenal coach and salary smart.
Very smart guys are actually taking shots to the head and there they don't seem
to be faced all.
I don't know what's going on.
It's nice.
We watched fight and you watched it did take a lot of Tylenol.
Dude.
That's the deal.
Yeah.
Martin Katherine was the head coach,
had MMA.
He replaced,
he ran,
he's going,
he's leaving out to campaigns are really tech.
Ooh,
nice uppercut.
Michael Johnson has been hit four times and he just keeps coming forward.
It was a great fight.
I guess we'll have to go over watching it.
We're on it.
We're not talking shit.
Right.
It's a good fight.
That's a problem with these God damn fucking paintings.
We miss amazing fights because the company's too good.
That's a fun.
Now,
by the way,
right during this right now is winning this round.
He's tagged him five times.
He's tagged Michael Johnson five times.
I pay the only round though.
Yeah,
well.
Oh goodness.
He keeps hitting him,
but it's really not fairly.
[inaudible] Johnson is slowed down at Johnson.
Slow down and I get a chance.
You know,
who knows how hard a time he has making one 55 a lot of these dudes have a hard
time making that wait,
man.
Yeah.
You see Diego Sanchez dropped to 45 crazy.
How crazy is okay flight in Ricardo Lamas,
right?
So Mexico.
So crazy.
Phenomenal fight and no,
let me ask you this.
What do you think about Rockhold dropping down to one 85 now with the lack of
IV.
So they take away your ivy when that starts in October,
right?
Right.
What are they fighting?
Why did I think they were fighting after that?
I thought they were fighting in September.
Am I wrong?
You might be right.
No.
Oh,
oh,
beautiful.
Left hand.
Where is it in September?
Where's it taking place?
You're right,
because you're right,
because in g Jamille find out for us either way,
but either way.
Rockhold the fucking dare you show the huge 80 fiber.
He's big and those Ivs,
I mean they got to have a man,
but do they,
because Joe Silva was trying to tell me that there's doctors that say it's
actually more effective to orally rehydrate.
You just have to do it correctly.
Come on.
Sing this true Joe.
Because in,
in,
in hospitals they rehydrate you with Ivs.
Right,
right,
right.
But maybe the,
you have to regulate and ensure that you get the right amount of fluid at the
right time.
And maybe there's a method to rehydrate and a lot of the time when you just
drink,
obviously you'd have talked to scientists,
but when you drink just water rehydrate,
it strips the electrolytes and actually doesn't rehydrate you if you use the Ip,
goes straight to the bloodstream to rejuvenate those Allison,
I would thought,
but I'm obviously not medically qualified to talk about it,
but one thing that Jeff Novitsky told me is that they do it because people can
use ivs to mask steroids.
Who's Jeff?
Jeff to Wicki is the guy that busted Lance Armstrong.
He's the guy that's the new USA drug dude.
Well plus doping and Joe Sullivan,
the guy who works for the UFC said Ivs are bad.
Well,
no,
they didn't say that,
but he said you should use,
but he didn't say that it was more effective.
He's,
he doesn't,
he doesn't engage.
There's no Wicki guys.
Very impressive.
Okay.
He doesn't engage
in propaganda,
doesn't engage in hyperbole.
He's very logical and very calm.
Very Fair.
I had a really good conversation with them and he's doing the podcast soon
because I need to,
you know,
I need to ask him a million questions about how these guys do things and how the
cyclists got away with it.
And we were talking about the Tour de France.
I was a good fight.
We were talking about the Tour de France and how this guy who was at the leader,
he goes,
he's got to be doing something.
He's breaking all the records at the juicers we're,
we're making.
He's like,
this guy is setting new record times and somehow or another he's testing clean.
And he said,
you know,
who knows what they're doing.
But the thing is they have,
they have steroids that they're developing testosterone that's not based on
plants.
Okay.
Because testosterone now though,
somehow or another,
they grow it with yams.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
It's insane.
And there's somehow or another they can test and they can find that it's
[inaudible] and dodginess that it's exogenous.
Yes.
That's the word.
They can't do that if it's animal stuff.
So they're figuring out a way to get testosterone for animals.
They're getting animal testosterone,
they're injecting it cause it mimics human bio identical.
It's bio identical and the can't figure out how to test it.
So if guys are doing that,
then it doesn't even look like they're on testosterone on a podcast can be so
dope.
Dude.
He's telling me crazy shit.
Tell me crazy shit about gene doping.
About the next level.
We,
you know I talked about what this with Rhonda Patrick on the podcast recently.
The next level it will by what you guys have to have her on.
Yeah,
we're going to have a real,
she'll blow your fucking listen to on your task her.
This is what you do cause for the fighter and the kid asked her to just study
steroids and what steroids you could hide and what steroids would do,
what and why you would take certain things where the benefits of it.
She'll look,
look through the research on it and come on your show and blow your fucking mind
below.
Really.
She's the smartest person I've ever talked to.
Whatever.
Yeah.
When I get her on the podcast,
just wind her up.
I just give her a subject like the last thing was cold shock protein.
She was talking about cryotherapy and the positive results of a sauna and that
sauna people had 40% less mortality across the board,
40% reduction in mortality,
whether it's cancer,
drugs,
a heart attack,
[inaudible] for longevity.
That's what she was saying.
There's something about heating your body up to 170 degrees.
You put it in that 170 degree environment for as long as the gins or something.
No,
it creates heat shock proteins.
She went into this big thing about heat shock proteins that are only create a
heat shock proteins and from cryotherapy,
very similar cold shock proteins.
Dude,
you've got to listen to the podcast because it's literally,
it's not even me.
It's like I would,
I would lob a ball at her and then I'd sit back for 20 minutes while she just
goes off and you've got to take notes.
You got to write shit down.
Damn,
she's a monster.
So getting your body at a certain temperature,
yes,
you relief triggers a compensatory response.
That compensatory response is called either heat shock proteins are cold shock
proteins and neoprene Efrin,
uh,
which is,
something that,
um,
it has an effect on mood and Nia.
How's it,
what's the word?
Net.
Neff.
Richard Neal.
Knepper tramp.
What happened here?
Fuck is that word that she is,
but anyway,
whatever it is,
it regulates I'm moody or your dairy.
Schwann.
Wow.
I didn't mean to cut you off Joe.
Sorry.
No worries.
Look at Michael Johnson's furious,
man.
I think Johnson definitely won that fight by the way.
We,
I do not think I was paying attention.
I was just enough.
You owe me dinner though,
and I found out that I shall like Daria,
she was actually robbed norepinephrine or epinephrine.
Thank you very much.
Sir.
Defined hasn't been booked yet either.
Oh,
it hasn't.
Which fight?
Which one?
White Man.
Black Hole.
They have to have a venue rumor that maybe December 5th,
but not officially yet.
Oh,
you know what?
I bet it's the big one because they're trying to do a big one December 5th.
That's what knucklehead shouldn't the shot.
She kept her mouth shut about the UFC calling in Dallas.
Yeah,
that's what they're saying.
They're saying,
listen,
you make one 35 if you may one 35 in Dallas,
December 5th let's do this.
But they got to,
she's going to have to get on the scale before they ever,
she's going to have to wait before bond is doing movies and shit so it has to
work for Rhonda Schedule II.
Well it's going to be December 5th if that,
if it's the big funds like rocky too.
This is what they're trying to do.
December 5th they're trying to do a gigantic arena in Dallas,
that huge football stadium and if they do cowboy stadium it is going to be the
motherfucker evolve motherfucker cards dude.
It's going to be like McGregor versus Aldo.
Rhonda versus Cyborg and if they signed fade or versus for doom and that's also
on the card and I also saw verse Holy Shit over and will be versus dos Santos
most likely you think they'll ever do a super bowl,
the card like that.
That would be the big card.
That would be the cross to do like and then Yolanda versus Claudia once a year.
Right?
Once a year.
If you have a supercar goddamn year.
Gimme a supercard.
Well,
there are apparently planning UFC 200 for now.
They're already advertising you.
Yeah,
there's half Al Cordero.
Great Guy.
Awesome coach just,
but it was so beautiful dude.
Always late.
Beautiful smile and just a warm friendly guide is true.
Loves a students.
Great Guy.
So they're already showing these teaser trailers would UFC 200,
which is next July.
So they're planning it.
Here's a fucking stud.
Matt Hughes and Stoller.
Robbie Lawler healed up like partners like Wolverine Wolverine.
You can't even tell him he was split open.
So awesome.
Too rough looking at UFC two hunters can be fucked dude.
How about,
um,
they're going to do Robbie Lawler versus Carlos Condit.
Brian County was called,
I can't wait for that.
How about this fight right here?
Max Hot Maxa versus a Olivera Max Holloway's a bad motherfucker did this going
on right now.
Connor,
this is coming up.
I called this one today too.
I did a um,
uh,
what else count on shells for this Max Holloway impressed though.
Fuck out of me.
Versus can you do those countdown shows?
Joe here,
I,
two of them near this area.
Gotcha.
Hernia,
California.
Well,
I didn't know if you have to go to like a UFC studio or what?
No,
we go to a sound studio.
Gotcha.
Yeah,
just a place.
There's a hundred of those spots in place.
Have you ever done those?
I do.
I do one for a video game too,
man.
I've been doing the video game again.
I did one for them for the top five greatest fights of all time and I went to a
unbreakable gym and just like,
oh,
that's cool.
Yeah.
Eric Sylville.
Rick Story.
Holy Shit.
That's a great fight.
Max Holloway and Charles Oliveira.
I fucking love that.
Jay Berkman to fun find boys.
What date is that?
August 23rd and we doing this or what?
It's a sudden day.
That sounds like a good day to do a fucking fight companion.
Who's here?
Hell yeah,
man.
I'm here.
We're going to on it and next week.
But that's it.
Then we go to Costa Rica next week.
It's a Sunday.
I like her next month on the 23rd which doing or not doing them 100% not doing
it.
No.
That's a fight.
That's a fight night.
Joe Says,
nut,
that's Brian Stann do.
It's going to come to w one day.
This is going to be too fun.
It's going to be like fight companion is going to be more fun than actually
being there at the fights.
Dude,
when I text you guys,
and especially when I take you,
I'm like,
Bro,
fight campaign for this.
You're like,
I'm out of town.
I'm like,
oh,
I know,
but it makes it sad.
When you said the other day and I said,
fuck yeah,
and you said fuck yeah,
so it makes my week.
He texted me FICA,
padded.
I go,
fuck yeah,
Shit.
The stars are aligning and then Callen cal tech's fee.
We're all texting each other.
The gang is back.
Ladies and gentlemen,
when we did think of painting without you,
it felt weird,
man.
How about Bobby girlfriend stole the show,
drop some knowledge shit.
She knew a lot more than I did.
Shut down,
shut down
totally body.
She was on the Filipino national swimming teams.
You're saying?
Yes.
If you have a woman as dominant as Ronda a man,
you're going to have to be some sort of an odd balance.
Man is submissive and small as Bobby Lee.
You're going to have to have a woman that takes up the slack.
I guess Wanda needs like a fucking Thor.
Just,
yeah,
just
like she's not going to go for Brock Lesnar.
Todd Duffy that's been in a lab like to toss artificial.
She's so Richie's and have some dude artificially created.
But like you were the one of the ones that said that Todd Duffy,
he's like insanely physically talented.
Right?
One of the bet might be the best I've ever seen in the gym.
Really mentally,
mentally.
It's just,
he struggles.
He's lost a few times by knockout and that's not even men's heavyweight can just
get cracked.
But if you see him move,
he's got an extremely impressive way of movement.
Like there's like,
this is a hard to describe,
but when you see guys fight so many times,
you see like thousands of thousands of fights up close.
One of the things you notice is if someone's sloppy in their movement,
if they're sloppy in their movement,
that they're probably sloppy in their thinking and they're probably sloppy
somehow in their preparation and it might just be a little bit,
but that little might be
they get,
they pull back and then they relax and then they get back up and then they go
in.
Whereas some some,
some guys have this like super efficient movement.
Like Anderson Anderson in his prime had this super efficient movement.
There was no slop in anything he did.
So when Anderson moved in on you and when he uncorked Shit on you,
it was just shooting.
It was just coming in out of nowhere,
which was half the magic of what he did.
He said there was fractions in milliseconds of things that were missing and his
movement that were available in other people's things you couldn't read,
couldn't read and he would do shit.
Like he was setting you up for stuff and you didn't know like when he find
kicked veto in the face three setting,
he was setting them up for,
he just saw the tours movement.
He saw how it's going in saying yeah and it comes out of nowhere and next thing
you know it's the ball of the foot to your chin.
That's there's,
there's some,
some guys don't recognize that unless you train that way,
unless you have this very,
very like a miserly approach to movement.
Like all that extra shit,
all this slicey where the hand drops or it comes with everything has to be
locked.
Like you watched Yolanda,
you want to inject check when she moves in,
that pitch is like locked down in lethal.
Everything is super efficient.
Like when you see her moving in,
everything is just locked into position and when the techniques come off its
way Duffy's that weight training,
that's what I'm saying.
This is why I think he has a,
uh,
the mental games not there for him.
Because when I saw him fight Frank Mir,
I'm like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Why are you running with your chin down,
throwing bombs?
He got excited if we'll side with that.
But that's everything.
You're right.
He's,
he's,
so,
I'm telling you,
man in the gym and I,
he went to Ak and I asked Daniel Cormier,
my calc gets Todd Duffy goes,
Bro,
that guy's a fucking monster and went right.
But for whatever reason,
it's just not translating.
So,
and this is,
this is a good way to tell if a guy's mentally strong,
and I'm not saying Todd's nut,
but there's an issue.
Look at the guys he's beat and then look,
when he fights someone who doesn't back down,
he's not scared of your body,
who's not scared of your previous records.
When you fight a vet who's like,
what you did?
What?
I'm not going to get knocked down by a single pump.
Well,
you know,
that's when you can tell the guy's record his defense.
He's had a long time off the UFC.
He went through a lot of health issues and I think he's getting back on track
and I think he doesn't have a lot of recent experience.
I mean he's got that one Anthony Hamilton fight where he knocked him out.
He looks spectacular in that fight.
And how many other fights is he has to it?
I think that's it.
I think that these back,
it's just that one.
Yeah.
That was his first fight back case with them before that.
But the lack of experience,
like he's his recent experience like for sure,
but,
but think about,
so he's,
you know,
you look at the guy,
he's,
he's beat,
you know,
he really hasn't been any big names.
Right.
But he hasn't fought any big names either.
He's the only fun style holster when he was in fraud.
Allister,
when Alister was on,
they
don't pull in lava out of the fucking right.
Out of insight right into his
duty.
Have you ever seen that surfer bro?
Even real human,
you know,
like silver surface services running over does a video,
the video of you looking at him as he's weighing in and you're just like,
ah.
That was when he fought Brock.
Oh my guy to 65 that was before they,
they all they did was urine tests back.
That's the only,
that's the only fight I've ever seen where when he weighed in I thought we're
all fucked.
Yeah,
we're calling dye wash up.
I should just retire right now.
You have to fight those guys.
Alistair Overeem the whole medicine cabinet and said,
have at it.
Sorry.
The most terrifying guy of all time.
He would never lose.
Yeah.
At his best when he was,
whatever he was on,
if he was on anything or now we know he got caught,
but who knows where.
That was
nice.
I liked the guy,
but my point being when he was that guy,
when he fought in k one like that,
when he was just jack to the fucking tidbits,
strict test,
he was a monster.
He had,
they made sure you were Ontario several days they test you and not enough.
He was a monster.
He's a monster.
I think that him at that level when he's at that level would be super hard to
beat.
But it's like when you get used to competing like that and you get used to being
at that level and then you're no longer anymore,
then the mental game kicks in for sure.
Hey Man,
don't look at him.
Look at
that photo.
He went first and Mister Olympia looking at that
body,
look at his arms.
You know he used to find that two or five.
I know I didn't say it to a five but I remember
the crazy thing is he said it was from horsemeat horseman and everyone and some
people find it.
Some people I was like what?
And then you pay your horse meat.
He's an answer to.
He never lets me look like Kermit the frog.
It's really crazy.
He's not even pumped up there.
See that's a guy who was just flacid and flexing.
Like when you lift weights it so thing like if you see a photo of someone and
they look giant,
they might've just lift weights and the arms literally get like twice.
You get pumped up and chill in there.
He's just relaxing in his underwear on a scale in [inaudible] Lesnar kicked
right in the fucking liver was like,
oh fuck.
This guy kicked right where he has served.
Yes.
I mean that's purpose.
The guy had 12 inches of his colon removed and then he fought a year later we
got 500 on this.
Right.
We've got five Honda man.
You think he's going to lose?
I think he's going to,
no,
I think osps get a win.
But just for the fun of this show,
I got clover take,
but for the record,
but I want to,
I wanna uh,
know that,
that that's how you can take global,
global,
I think global is going to win by submission.
Some it's going to really hurt your feelings change over.
It's going to block and knock them out.
Glover's wanting to hurt.
I just want to go over as a very composed,
when constant Prue knocked out Pat Cummins,
he woke me up.
My eyes won't be knocked out.
The
nice apricots think his back foot.
I think he's talented as fuck.
I've always loved what he's doing is he's getting better.
He's getting more and more skillful in the way he knock out Shogun with that
beautiful step aside.
Left hook confidence is a big thing.
He likes twist.
That was spectacular.
He's got all these victories by knockout and he's like the twist.
Who?
Dobby guy.
I think he's the only guy in history in MMA.
He got someone in the truck and got him on a calf crank.
He's,
he's always in the truck.
Go scars on his arm.
I'm going to say some omega.
They burned them.
That would make you like,
wouldn't that create some texture?
Wouldn't that make it difficult like for you to slip out of stuff?
Like if you,
if you decide if someone was so gangster,
they discard a scar.
All their arms from their wrist all the way up to the top of their shoulder so
they have a more textured skin so I can get a chokes.
So he couldn't slip out of good teams and slept dedication,
bro.
Somebody found out if someone found out that there was a way of creating scarf
vacation than made a textured surface.
It and scars don't sweat the same way.
A restrict skin swells burn their skin like dark man.
So many did that a long process and created like a super textured skin.
All of their products Friday Kruger Bro.
Like Freddy
does that well think about,
hey do do a lot of scarification.
Yeah and Africa,
they actually date,
they try,
they scratch their backs and sometimes they die and go into shock and all that,
but they,
they'll scan our entire back to look like a crocodile.
Yeah,
I've seen that.
I think by far the better athlete.
I just think Glover has more experience and dude,
when I trained with Glover,
his wrestling and grappling,
he,
he hasn't showed it much,
but he's a fucking nightmare.
Well his,
his top game is heavy.
When he got Kyle Kingsbury in the ground,
you could see like,
Ooh,
that's a heavy top game.
His arm chairs,
I'm like a sweater,
Joe Sweat coming in and [inaudible] Chuck Liddell.
Right.
But also you gotta think those six years he was out of the UFC,
we're six years of his prime.
When he was chuckling.
Dell's main training partner,
but he's high on them.
We stopped.
Uh,
he was the first guy to,
um,
uh,
what the fuck is his name?
It looks like the Predator,
the crazy dreadlocks.
So could you,
he was the first guy that knocked out,
so yep.
He knocked out.
So could you and the WAAC or was the WEC or palace?
It was WC.
WC.
And uh,
that was the first time I saw Glover.
Fine.
I was like,
Whoa,
this dude,
he's gangster.
There's so much hype on them though.
From everyone though.
Yeah,
but you gotta think,
man.
He's like,
what?
37 38 now how old is he?
36 Jamie.
Find out how old the Glover is all man.
Reality.
It's fucking,
man.
The reality is if he's not doing anything,
if you get to this stage in boxing,
if you get to this stage,
like back in the day when no one was taking anything,
right,
like the Marvin Hagler era,
we assume nobody was taking anything.
It's hope,
but guy got to be like 36 it's a fucking end of the road over over.
All dogs go to heaven.
Yeah,
sober.
All Tom's going to have the line of the night.
It's over and it's true.
All dogs got it.
Is it was the line of the night earlier was,
yeah,
there was another one before that team
now,
but there's even,
there's another one too.
I don't really know.
Why don't you just stand up?
Come on dude.
You can do it.
Believe me,
if you could do it on this podcast,
you can do it on stage.
You would love it.
I agree.
You 100% could do it.
This is what you should do.
I just want to do it and hang out with you guys at night anytime.
I just want to recently,
I know.
How am I going to start writing and just,
I will go over some stuff and just get up and that's what you guys,
here's what you do.
This is your move ready.
You go on the road with Brian and Brian brings you up and you do like five
minutes.
That's it.
He tells a story for five minutes.
Even if it bombs,
you laugh and then you bring him back and then you know everything's groovy
cause he's just no expectations.
He's sick.
I mean I'm not scared.
I just don't want to disrespect.
Disrespect like saying I don't want to try Jujitsu cause I don't want to
disrespect you Jitsu.
Everything else.
Everybody sucks at first.
And you'll be funny because you're funny.
You're ready.
Great Dude.
You could do it 100% I'm down right now.
Keyboard warriors all across America goal you guys,
you're fucking ridiculous.
He's not funny.
He's a fucking share screen and everyone's not funny.
You're not funny.
Fuck you.
Stop trying to get everybody to do comedy.
Stop telling everybody.
Do a podcast.
It worked.
Look,
they got guys worked at Ted.
The podcast is stellar.
Let's start down.
The biggest thing to start doing,
I want to get you after five minutes,
you're gonna come on the road with me.
You can do it easy.
By the way,
just tell,
start by telling a story.
Giant,
crazy live show.
If he did that,
it'd be nuts.
He's 35 then we got our live show,
by the way.
October 1st Bram,
Bram prom tickets just went on sale.
First live show.
Just went on sale shoots.
Oh,
I'm going to be at the Cop Theater September 4th in Vegas with Ian Edwards and
Greg Fitzsimmons.
Ooh,
we just had Greg gun.
He's a funny dude.
He's,
he said you gotta let roommates and then of course I went,
you ever seen his dick?
And he went,
no I didn't.
I went,
you were roommates know checked out his dick.
Yeah,
I hear Greg's got a piece on him though.
I,
that's the rumor.
I just have a little Dick.
It's not little.
Well,
no,
he said it's like winning.
I'm just,
well he's a little guy.
You don't have to throw you off.
Yeah.
If that was like three off and Rothwell wouldn't look so big.
There you go.
Oh,
you're going to be here next week.
Ben Looks like his music or just saying he shoots gimme a hug the other day.
I was like,
he's so big,
so big and hairy.
It wasn't like fighting that dude.
I was so cocky.
I thought I was going to smoke them.
I thought was spinning elbow landed because I never trained before.
I saw John do it.
I was like,
Oh,
I'm going to do that against Rothwell never trained it.
Landed,
wobbled him.
Guess what?
The last words before I went in the cage cage,
my coaches know me.
They go,
listen,
you have better cardio.
Better technique.
Let's drag this in the third round.
Yeah.
Cool.
When in spin an elbow nuts knocked out.
I like this
bad idea.
Here we go.
Open.
Same proof.
Find out a Knoxville,
Tennessee bitches.
I think it's crazy that Bruce buffer does all this amazing passionate shit and
they never show it on TV.
I love watching it.
It's one of my favorite things to water show it.
They was cut to that like a crowd shot might be one of my favorite Americans.
Terrorist Swift said it best.
Haters.
Gonna hate hate.
That's a nice song.
It's true.
Those lyrics notice for Bruce.
Buffer is going off right now.
He's listened to it.
Can we hear it Jamie?
He's going off.
We just don't see them.
What's basically over here?
Here we go.
Keep it cranking.
Did he jumps and spins right here?
Watch.
Look at it.
Yeah.
They pulled back on them.
They hold back.
You got a little dish.
Why hate on Bruce?
I don't know.
Here's the,
they're going to do the best ref in the game right there.
Give him the reach around,
right?
That big boys got to set a tits on him.
He's just some big fighters right here.
I liked the big John's doing this and the two married a good referee here.
I wonder why Bruce doesn't just give big John to Mike.
So you take the mic.
Hey hear.
Hear me out.
Hear me out here.
Why not?
What?
OSP,
right.
Uh,
USA Glover.
Brazil.
Why not have the trunks if you're going to do them like that,
they have this name,
but to make it different,
why not have the trunks a yellow and green and black and then have osps really
say killer.
It's a bad idea,
bro.
His wrestling is fucking good.
OSB early,
early.
It's tough to take down.
Trust me.
Super tough.
Take down.
As the rounds go on,
it gets easier and easier as clover took him right to Osp off his back.
No Bueno.
Just took him right down,
right and a half card.
That was him to pay you right now too.
That was impressive.
I can pay you next time a year.
It's kind of fun.
He's a beast on the ground,
man.
Super Beast on top.
So dangerous on top.
He's got such good control.
You know what LSPs worst thing is?
Oh,
look at all that great control.
All so great little ground and pounds.
You'd osps hips.
You're right though.
No,
you're right.
but he look,
Osp got out of there,
man.
For sure.
Oh,
low rates.
Osps hips,
manners from football.
Someone doesn't have a diamond cup.
Diamond MMA cups.
Gotta have a Diamond Cup.
Took one right to the jewels.
Just like a diamond shaped piss whole took one to the Asai Berries.
That's never fun.
Especially my trying to grind to get help.
Okay.
Right now he lied because it just takes way longer than no.
Sometimes.
No.
Sometimes there's pressure,
man.
You don't need five minutes for no,
but there's pressure.
The fans are like,
come on is obviously levels of healing.
We're going to size of his ass.
I'm like Jesus.
Oh,
you rock them my money right now.
Oh my God.
Look at this.
Opens has got ahold of,
look at this bull shit.
You pay me?
No.
Oh,
Hammer fist.
Did he pay me now?
200 bucks.
No Sir.
Just give it to me.
Oh,
look at his elbow.
I'll wait then to open st proves a monster.
Super Athletic Monster.
Oh,
he's funny.
He's super fucked up.
Oh,
speeds about to win.
Go over.
It's very good in these situations.
So it's how he knocked out Ryan Bader to the body,
man.
Oh,
look at this.
When you go straight to mouth.
Kidding me.
Robos,
lovers,
ground game.
Ah,
crazy fight.
Hey,
he's going to roll cause there he goes.
He's,
he gives back but he's high.
He's high on the back man.
He's signed the back.
Oh Jesus.
Good control.
But you kidding me,
right?
He likes that arm triangle.
Oh boy.
Whoo.
There's going to explore that a damn ground game.
Explain a lot of time on Friday.
Bravo loyalty.
He will.
I hear you dude.
But you gotta be impressive.
Go over here.
No,
you're not impressed.
Hey yes,
do it.
This is wicked.
And plus he was tested here.
I love omits his left kick man that left to the and got him taken down as it
did.
But the one before is what started off that combination.
Raise clover hurt for sure.
You can't just do this.
He's going to roll this back and get out.
Louise too high.
He's got to stand up.
Stand up.
Cool.
Little critical moment here.
Right?
But man,
what you do here,
she's doing right now hand fighting stance.
Cause here's one hook in Stan and hand fight and he was trying to create that
opening.
Try and create that.
Ow.
Oh ow.
Oh,
oh shit.
He got up.
He's about to get taken down.
That was crucial cause he was like a movie,
right?
Yeah.
But I'll tell you what.
Orphans landed some fucking hard shots while he's trying to take him down
earlier.
They ain't no picnic standing up with him.
Fuck No.
You separate that left kick to the body and to the head.
Oh,
on the feet.
OSPS better.
I think he's dangerous as fuck cause fuzzing kicks.
All clover does is he's like a boxer.
He's like a really good rampage who can grapple is what I think.
Well it's also woven ties.
Those two big knockouts over shogun.
He's calming.
Take down.
Wrestling is ridiculous.
Tony.
It's so funny or good.
Ah,
he's a,
he's a beast.
Look it over.
It's looking for the fucking Paul Harris.
That's what we're going to call it from now on.
It's not the Camorra anymore.
It's the Paul Harris in the morning to recover too.
He is the amount of to write to mount.
Damn,
I'm Ken.
This is exhausting for over in saint pro super cost.
Especially if you're not a grappler.
We wind up in guard here.
Some serious ass up game where they say approve loves the Von Flowers.
Yeah,
he does to do it.
Yup.
It's over.
He might get the von flue here and we might go,
shit,
what was going out?
He's going,
he's going out.
It's sometimes sometimes the gloves duck.
No.
Globish smart.
He's turning away from it.
Wow.
This is close to the to do.
Those are two good grappler,
dude.
Look at this man.
He stuck.
I jumped into top half gold lock down and let the guy get on top of me and I
finished one of my back.
It's easier from the border.
You do.
Eddie had jumped in the top half.
They take it.
I locked down their legs in advance.
Let them roll on top of me.
And it's easier from the back with the lock that,
so this position right here on flu lockdown.
Yep.
Oh Man.
Proofs.
Kickers.
Kidding me.
Are you kidding me?
Kick please kick.
His kicks are awesome.
Oh look at that.
That's a bad idea.
That's a horrible idea against,
he's such an athlete,
like the way he moves.
He's got so much fucking horsepower behind him.
He does.
He does in his ass.
[inaudible] ass.
That's a Kim Kardashian ass.
Look at it.
Maybe after she goes to Brazil for critters.
Got To shit or on them for sure.
Hey,
critters kind of shit.
So No,
you mind.
Oh,
you did kind of a bitch.
Sorry.
I'm going to have to ask you to,
who is this?
Some dude who runs fast and now five signs.
He's an actor.
The MONTEL Williams.
Isn't it
some Zombie movie?
Is this the day of the dead or some shit?
Is this the new walking dead one or Montel Williams is not what this is.
You know there's a new walking dead.
Rose is he called it of the dead.
I Dunno.
Like switch it up though.
Well,
the idea is to keep it as close as possible because it's the same same writers
sit a walk and have like a chain of them.
Gotcha.
It's something super close like run of the dead or jog of the dead.
It's smart man,
because everybody who loves that show,
he can't get enough of it.
I can't get enough of that shit.
First two seasons.
Good walking daily.
I need a shell.
So fun.
I love it.
Let me ask you this though.
Rogan,
let me ask you this into here.
What the new one takes place here in la?
Yeah.
Well the old one took place in Atlanta.
There's no blacks,
zombies and walking dead.
It's in Atlanta,
so they pale up the pill up with little shit.
They do pay a lot of it Belloc ones actually,
but it would be,
there'd be a lot more dead.
Right?
Real problem.
That is a big strong man.
Get that Shit you played for Tennessee volunteers.
Is that kick to the body?
His kicks are nasty man.
Power behind them.
Ouch.
And he's another guy that just gets more and more efficient.
He loves that upper cut to,
he gets more and more fish off,
but by the way,
there is a hell of a box overs.
More technical intros.
Real short chest.
There's that first or second again,
kid,
you got a good point.
But look or events say no.
Back to his feet.
Come out of cardio.
Left's gonna come down to cardio cars or knock.
He's never been in dangerous rounds like championship Brown clover clover's
never been knocked out.
Right.
We'll go over,
starting to slow down or excuse me,
Osp.
Starting to slow down a little bit here and we're at four minutes.
She looked at the clock.
A lot of muscle feed,
oxygen,
muscle feed,
oxygen to,
well,
he's just body.
She's gotta be aware of what he's doing because he's exploding.
He's not as mechanical efficiency.
Better box.
He keeps looking better cock.
That's a bad sign,
man.
Well,
you know what?
Clovers,
just wasting less time movement,
but the movement that Osp does so much pop behind it.
You can only do that for so long though.
No matter how athletic you are.
Yep.
That's again,
getting,
taking skin.
He's going for a run and clover,
so strong.
Same smile.
Smile.
He smiles is my son.
He's like,
I'm winning and you know what?
He's wearing his ass.
He's a better fighter.
Eddie Bravo.
Any brought you want to check the cash?
You want to check her calendar right now?
I'll give you 200 right now to get out of,
we call it 200 200 cash cash right now.
Take your
shit deal.
Take the money.
Sure he should wait a minute.
Come on in the fight.
Still gone.
Make the deal right now with cash,
money,
cash out.
Then he cut his losses and only time we ever really caught damage.
Control your own foot off,
but you still got your life.
Well,
you don't want to get fuck cardio.
Fight with OSP.
He's not going to win that one being that explosive.
Yeah,
I didn't look good.
It's the second round.
It doesn't look good.
So I got,
I think I made out.
Yeah,
you're just can kind of chillax down here and take a little break Ipu and just
defend himself.
Well telling you when you're eating elbows.
That's true.
To share our elbows.
It's very tough to do.
You know what?
Just
come back later.
Let's,
uh,
let's go back your,
how about this?
How about you make an alternative bet since you're going to let him out,
$73.
How about you?
How about you bet,
whether or not OSP makes it past five is he getting make it past the fifth?
No,
I'm just going to get finished.
He's going to get say right now,
not a shy double or nothing and got a shot at not a shot.
He goes back.
I'll take anybody's bad shot.
He laughs too.
I'll bet at two grade he doesn't make it.
I say it doesn't last till around three he just is too type much.
Do you want to bet and we can,
we can then and go back to the original one.
If I feel,
oh he's coming back.
You have a right to refusal,
but I'm going to give you the option.
We'll just,
we'll just add it to the next.
It's coming back.
I'll go.
We we and all this shit.
I will see go back,
but right now we're good.
I think.
I think Osp,
a Tko a third round gets Tko.
Okay,
Brian,
is that what you think too?
Fuck.
Yeah.
Who wants to know?
Wants to give me a good bet that it goes the full five shot.
I bet you anything wrong really?
Can you give me 10 to one?
I sometimes fights 10 to one.
All right.
10 to $100 oh no.
I don't want to bet that much.
A hundred dollar dollar two and 10 I'm looking to maximize,
but front's gone for an electric chair
of Veggie tend to win a hundred.
I'm not taking the money anyway,
but Glover's beating his ass though.
That's for fuck shore.
He's hitting them with some serious ground.
I'm always cutting them up with that elbow
is not making it.
No.
30 minutes over.
This is the glow over the beat.
Ryan Bader,
this is the glow over that was making his run at the title.
He's a beast.
People slept on him a little bit in this fight.
His grappling fees getting over in saint proves the underdog.
It was Friday,
correct?
No,
he's the favorite.
Oh my God.
Well,
I would've thought there'd be even money.
Quite honest.
It was almost even.
It was like plus one oh five
mm.
No,
no,
no.
He's gonna get taken down easy and get his ass.
He's so tired.
They're both so tired.
You know,
like Glover said,
he said,
uh,
in the Phil Davis fight in Brazil.
He just didn't cut the weight right and he was exhausted.
So he just got fucking grappled for five rounds was also a lot of people felt
like,
you know,
he didn't go to American top team for that fight.
He stayed in Connecticut and train in his garage.
He did too.
I thought that kick back.
Oh.
Oh Shit.
Clovers.
Tired as fuck.
Oh Shit.
Son.
Want to go back
back?
Thank God Eddie Bravo didn't pay out back.
We're fighting back.
I'm eating.
You know what?
We're back.
I lost faith and I must shamed of that boy.
I am ashamed when you lose,
you look into my eyes and I give it back to you.
Look at my eyes.
I give you strap ashamed of that,
but I feel now he's coming back and he's going to take this and you're gonna to
me mind after seeing that and explain to you both,
you got one complaint.
Is there any way we can get more Ronda Rousey ads?
This is ridiculous.
Famous though.
A little mud.
She's a two guys that can handle her.
Two guys,
thorn soldiers,
Demetrius Johnson,
Captain America,
the thing.
And Conor Mcgregor,
I [inaudible] handle it.
She would eat him alive.
I could,
yes,
I could.
Cause your superfund was,
she would hate,
no,
I would have sex with her a lot.
I haven't had sex with her a lot and,
and I break her walls down and I'd be super nice to her and make a lot.
It's watch his fight.
Hang on half and half tax from his left kick of tries or with my peace.
Quick goals to the,
we go,
here we go.
By the way,
open say true might just pull this out dude.
He could pull it out.
He's exhausted to take it.
That it can come back from being exhausted.
He's not,
he could recover.
Recover,
no to do recovery.
He's
still,
he's hurt Goldberg Glover just hurt him.
Who has to run.
He has to do a lot of running cause he needs to get off the fucking day.
Faints or beautiful Glover's footwork and his faints.
He stank just far enough that he knows like what opens can do right now.
That's a nice idea.
He knows like the amount of spring he's got left at his staff,
he's calculating it.
Well look,
he's going to take them down again.
It's going to pop his hips to lift him up or trap is going to scoop him right in
the fucking air.
This who's going to do boom,
oh Vince,
time to carry some weight.
He didn't get finished this round.
Four minutes or some way.
Eddie,
do you,
would you like to get to that?
I mean that he's going to have be on the ground.
He's,
he's going to wear him.
He's too tired to get these.
Think he's too tired.
It doesn't go past third round.
I think he can still get up,
man.
I'm not under going to get it in this guy.
This kids got mad heart.
I think [inaudible] is a tough fucking dude.
I think he finishes them this round.
I think he's not as mechanically efficient as he can be in the future because he
explode so much in everything.
But I think that's also a strength training wrong.
I'm also his strength.
He should some boxers and run.
Maybe that would help for sure.
But it's also something that he does to people.
They don't expect the amount of explosion that he jumps into that success with.
Yeah.
I've worked with Matt only to a certain level.
And then when you fight a vet,
a true vet who has seen that,
you don't think Glover seen the explosive guy before,
what,
you know what the deal is?
He's got to be able to do both and got to know when to do in Schwatz.
Yes,
yes.
You gotta know when to do it and do each one,
but I think right now he's not quite as technically proficient as like a guy
like Glover where Glover throws short combinations and they're snowshoes and
efficient.
Yeah.
I think,
oh,
Vince hasn't like reached that level yet,
but oh,
Vince can hit fucking hard.
He's keeps working for that mounts.
Look at that.
That's going to get finished here.
Ah,
look up,
look down.
Look at this shit.
Look at that.
Look at how you earn your money.
Good control man.
Glover's cannot turn out.
That mount is so nasty.
I remember money by fame.
Dick jumped on the fire and the kid got bad brother.
Once he,
once he got on top of cow Kingsburg really see that mountain.
I was like,
Ooh,
that's a scary ass fucking mount.
He's strong as shit too man.
You know the other thing about Ose,
super strong.
The other thing about Osb,
if he didn't train at a high level camp,
which they train,
he trains in Tennessee at this.
Oh my God,
he don't have like a lot of high class training gets fucked up dude.
He's got fucked up.
He didn't get finished.
Can I tell you and Eddie Bravo.
Gimme my 500 he's going to Tash.
Yeah,
that's
done.
That's too deep.
And he's gone to sleep and and let's he's out.
He's out.
He went out.
Wow.
Eddie,
I'm sorry to say thank you.
With respect to Osp,
he was thinking about tapping and to Matt decided I'm not to shop.
He went out map and look at how awesome lover over,
it's like the nicest guy.
A great called killer.
Nice guy.
Got a fucking great guy.
What a a crazy moment that is.
When a fighter decides not to tap,
it's pretty gangster.
Fuck.
Sometimes they don't know though.
You think you're like,
you know,
I'm going to them.
Yeah,
it's true.
It's true.
You're like,
I'm going to find the house.
Look at this.
Look at this combination.
Mitch,
you're young.
Gave a thumbs up when I'm going to Doris.
I say,
cool story,
Bro.
Look at this fucking right here man.
And then watch when he cinches it up onto the bicep.
Look,
why wouldn't you tap Lee's name and fighting?
He's trying to fight the one hand he has got that squeeze on it and that's how
it is.
So awesome.
I like my car so fucking awesome.
I love that guy.
He's the best legit Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt too.
He knows exactly what's going on in there.
Fuck,
this is good for Ospi though,
man.
Two minutes.
We're done.
Yeah.
Hey,
perfect timing.
What a fucking fight.
Combat.
Great for us.
B to learn from this.
Eddie,
you owe me $500 we'll do it for the next fight is going to be here next weekend.
Next weekend.
Oh yeah.
It's like you're gonna be here next Saturday.
You're going to be our next Saturday.
If you give me an invite,
I'll catch a little the VIP ticket downtown down,
son,
if you're listening,
I got a submission only Jujitsu tournament going on next Saturday.
It's going to be on butoh videos.com Saturday might be tweeting about it all.
Next album all tweet up.
Go to Youtube and search Ebi for countdown show on Youtube.
And then that'll explain what it's all about.
He hot fucks.
Eddie Bravo.
I'm on Twitter.
A 10th planet.
J j.com Instagram,
the Real Eddie,
Bravo,
Instagram,
Dakota,
Eddie Brock.
Time.
Somebody gagged on Cactus Shit.
So I'm super famous.
[inaudible] with a y B,
a rite aid and Cowen,
a fighter and the kid podcast or the formerly of the Brian Cowen experience.
Shop and shop on Twitter,
the fighter and the kid watched fighter in the kid.
And when are you gonna Bring Back Eddie Bravo radios that can happen.
That's coming as he come on the fire of the kid,
the kid live improv tickets are on sale Bray improv.com.
Thank you guys.
I'll,
I'd love to be on your show.
God Damn it.
Make it handed off here.
So we'll have you on and you can make,
we love doing these things and we appreciate all the positive energy that we get
for you guys.
And we,
we know we get super psyched when you guys get psyched that we do these,
we get fired up.
There's just so much fun because we are 100% ourselves on these things and uh,
get to fuck off and have fun.
It's a very unusual thing to be able to do.
So I appreciate the Fuck Eddie guys.
This is an awesome,
I appreciate
you guys for 20 years almost.
Now how about that?
It's been,
or how about that?
We're so lucky.
That's,
I think one of the most important things in life is having cool friends and
their friends' friends.
I drove to the comedy store yesterday.
I had no other reason.
I said,
maybe Joe's there.
I see you right in the park.
And I got out and we hang out for two hours just talking about it.
They always say the coolest shit.
It's a shit you don't expect the
shit you didn't plan for.
And like this crew,
we didn't plan this shit and it's kind of just happened.
We'll find a fucking a night.
You know what I mean?
Guys,
thank you very much.
See you guys soon.
Bye.
Sorry man.